you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body in it not a
big human food market
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're getting louder with crowder
and that sound means
that sound means it's the weekend i am
your host of the show lotto with crowder
stephen credit producing with me in
studio if you're listening to rest
really and one of one of our wonderful
affiliates uh producing with me in
studio as always is
not gay jared you can follow him at
twitter at not gay jared he is not gay i
fulfill my legal obligations and you can
draw your own conclusions are we good
good good another day and it's like a
nike did you plan that rhyme
no i didn't plan on that but it worked
out well it worked out well worked out
really well sometimes you just fall
backwards into things that work for you
sometimes your friend fall from words
into things that turn out okay too back
to you stephen okay thank you very much
and uh man what kind of what a show do
we have we have quite the shin big for
you this evening it's gonna be good ben
shapiro coming on
or this morning you know don't know when
else this evening morning depending on
when you're you could be in china you
could be in china
by the way if you're in china you guys
have some problems
i mean listen
i know it's a homogenous culture but
there are still billions of them it's
like world war z at a certain point
they're just they're just going over
that wall and they just become human
stairs i don't want to throw china under
the bus talk about the zombies still no
we're talking about the chinese
but i repeat myself what what racism in
the very first segment how how great is
this so
we have ben shapiro the world's favorite
uh snarkiest jew great guy gotta love
gotta love the jewish ben shapiro and uh
tim kennedy so contrast you have ben
shapiro intellectual not necessarily
confused as a tough guy and then tim
kennedy ufc top contender uh former army
ranger host of killing hitler hunting
hitler hitler hunting host on that show
hunting hitler and then of course
courtney scuffs are wonderful are
wonderful my wonderful editor who by the
way courtney if she is listening or
watching thank you so much she had a
vacation i know she was burnt out and uh
things would not work at
lighterworthcredit.com without the team
of uh courtney of course our mick brody
casey is the newest one and she is just
great and she had to make her twitter
private because everyone was was hitting
on her in ways that were sexually just
wildly inappropriate but they meant to
be complimentary the internet's a very
bizarre place
and i don't know if i'm missing anybody
no i think that covers it
i think you need to send the uh the
weird compliments to me i would i would
take those over over you know no you
weren't on a thank you list notice you
didn't get a christmas card you just my
calling for my firing which is usually
appropriate usually usually fair we had
a problem with the stream even starting
today so a lot has happened this week i
don't it sounds to me like i'm in a
fishbowl is there something going on it
sounds like way too but i think it's
just your voice
for some reason it sounds like the
studio maybe it isn't padded or
something like usual i don't know what
that is well the uh
the duct tape doesn't hold up as well
doesn't hold up no they're keeping the
phone all right anyway a lot of news
this week wisconsin coming up that's
going to be big by the time you're
listening to this and you're hearing
this
and uh some numbers came out so we have
a few stories one that i find hilarious
and we have up at live earthquaker.com
an employee at a university uh beat the
talk well didn't beat the tar grabbed
and manhandled a student for cultural
appropriation for those who do not know
this is uh it means that something is
racist
and uh well i'm kind of a big deal it's
a big deal for people in our generation
and the cultural appropriation was this
white kid was wearing dreadlocks
apparently this girl had never seen a
corn music video like that's all it was
on mtv the early 2000's was really bad
guitaring and just swinging of
dreadlocks so apparently
in defense of the
dreadlocks on a white dude just it's not
dreadlocks on anybody don't look good
the guy bob marley they look worse on
they look bad on bob marley bob marley
has dreadlocks you associate it with him
if bob marley had any other haircut
including the burger king kids club
house party high and tight he'd still
look better dreadlocks look awful
and i don't think you can wash them very
effectively anyway so that's a story
we'll talk about that later on a girl
was pepper sprayed at a trump rally
awful 15 year old girl pepper sprayed
terrible but the media lied to you said
that someone had groped her and then
they pepper sprayed her no one groped
her
from what we know now at the recording
of this broadcast and she did full wine
sucker punch somebody and then someone
pepper sprayed her so it's just ugliness
all around all around the world all
across the american political spectrum
you know in this studio
thank god you people never actually have
to set foot in this studio with the
immune system that we both have not gay
jared and i and living such close
proximity with each other we would be
marvels of science if you could just
take a skin graft into a petri dish
so the first thing i wanted to lead with
though
is
obamacare these new numbers came out now
we've been talking about this for a long
time i hate to do the i told you so but
i love doing the i told you so so new
report came out and um this also ties
into ted cruz who was on with jimmy
kimmel we'll talk about later uh where i
have a quote right here obamacare
enrollees are sicker than those covered
before the law backers see this as good
news because it means those needing
coverage are getting it but it's
actually a sign of an impending death
spiral not a good sign when you use
death spiral a new report from blue
cross blue shield finds that those who
signed up for obamacare in 2014 and 2015
had higher rates of various diseases and
used significantly more medical services
in their first year of coverage
uh
they go on to say but to work obamacare
had to bring in young and healthy people
to offset the costs of the older and
sicker to keep insurance premiums down
otherwise the market would enter into a
death spiral where high premiums with
more healthy pete would drive healthy
people out of the market pushing rates
up further this is exactly what's
happened
where obamacare has been implemented
which is crazy when you think this is
what leftists knew would happen i talked
about this a long time ago no one else
really cared anthony weiner i know well
let's get let's get grow up
grow up
anthony penis got a he got a an
exemption for obamacare a lot of these
leftists uh got their districts or got
their con their voting constituency they
got them exempt so they supported
obamacare we had to know it was in the
bill to pass it so anthony weiner i just
say because it's a name that sticks in
your mind because his last name is a
synonym for a donegar so you know
anthony weiner if i name you
some other congressman
or senator you might not remember the
name but anthony weiner um the guy who
got caught showing his wiener grow up
who got an exemption for obamacare now
if you look at their justification it
was because they understood the costs
hillary clinton has said that she may uh
use and it may enact an executive order
to stop the crushing costs of obamacare
premiums have gone up 49
deductibles now usually if you pay a
higher premium you would expect a lower
deductible right with obamacare that was
the promise no premiums have gone up an
average of 49 by the way that's a very
broad number for most people who are
working and had an average plan if
you're middle age it's gone up much more
than that but at least 49 all the
sources at ladder with credit.com
deductibles have skyrocketed for many
people doubled or tripled people are
getting less for their healthcare
than ever with this
and it's this goes back to fundamental
economics this is why i did the video on
why democratic socialism doesn't work
what do you think is going to happen
you're basically forcing insurance
insurance companies are making a bet
right what they're saying is okay if we
have x amount of people let's say we
have x amount of people paying 200 a
month
and their deductible is 5 000
we know that if we charge this amount
we'll have enough people and uh most of
them will not use their deductible
therefore we will make x amount of
profit that's how their business model
works it's very very mathematical tight
there's nothing sexy about it and then
the government comes in and says no you
have to cover everyone they say well
hold on our math doesn't allow for
people who who
who eat a diet of snickers and fried
oreos and um and then dessert
coming on to our healthcare plan with
diabetes and gout gout's still a thing
it's still a thing but it doesn't really
come from most people aren't getting it
from from iron-rich food they're getting
it from being fat s obese a lot of
people are getting encountered
so saying we didn't account for this and
that government says well you can't deny
these people for pre-existing conditions
now i understand that a lot of insurance
companies were denying people for pre
you know like well listen you cracked
your your knuckles are cracking we can't
accept you i understand that insurance
companies are terrible this entire law
was big kickback to the insurance
companies so again their business is
betting it's betting on health and now
you have thrust into their risk pool a
bunch of people
who are unhealthy a bunch of people who
everyone else has to subsidize so this
is where we are anyone who understands
basic economics knew this is what was
going to happen that's what republicans
said what happened this is what
conservatives said what happened this is
what's happened in canada this is what's
happened in all these democratic
socialist countries that bernie sanders
loves to praise it's just a matter of
time it's a ticking time bomb and just
like we talked about john stossel talked
about this when you have insurance and
now you have a lot of young people who
get to subsidize insurance
you go you get whatever you want like
you're saying sick people but they're
using a bunch of services that maybe
they don't even need ah the back of my
neck hurts i'm gonna go in and get an
mri uh
i don't know i i my toe hurts i think i
might have gout although if you're 420
pounds you might have gout that's
actually not
it's not frivolous
i'd get it checked out completely
reasonable it's completely reasonable
for the 400 pound guy with a sore toe to
think he might have gout
so i don't want to speak out of turn
as i often do
um
and the the point is we all saw this
coming and you were told no no no no no
this is not true this is going to be
great
and something that's really important
we've talked about this same thing with
unemployment hillary clinton and bernie
sanders said barack obama is great for
for unemployment the unemployment rate
is low the economy is recovering they
say that when he's in office right
but when they're running
they say it's over 11 percent yep
why because it's one thing to lie at
that point when you're in office you're
lying to the press it's a pr thing but
when you need to gain votes
at some point you have to be honest with
people and that's just such a blatant
lie if you say well employment is low no
you know it's bad and see well it's 11
here's how i'm going to fix it for you
because they you know this hero worship
with politics well the same thing with
the uh you know the jobs are doing great
the economy is booming but wall street's
really screwing people right now and no
one's getting any money they it's it's
it's rigged and going downhill when they
want to go downhill and it's going
uphill when it benefits them right for
the reports so yeah exactly and then
they they [ __ ] about how wages haven't
gone up right
who's been at the tiller like bernie
sanders people who vote bernie sanders
or hillary clinton to fix our problems
you're like 10 second tom you can't
remember the last seven years
it's been them
we'll be back we'll talk cultural
appropriation stay tuned later with
crutter everybody
in fact
but they fought with desperate timing
this is breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm perry mathewson we take you
now to the live stream where donald
trump has stopped in his campaign
for tommy tibble's fifth birthday party
oh wow legos thanks so much mr trump
thanks so they're very expensive legos
okay those were they're gold-plated okay
frankly have the other one
okay who wants cake yes oh yeah great
thanks mom
can i blow up the candles only if you
make a wish first all right
this is the best birthday ever food
fight hey excuse me okay i didn't clear
food fight this [ __ ] is worth 9 000 are
you gonna pay for the dry cleaning okay
mr trump it was just excuse me okay here
i am i buy these gold-plated legos okay
the nicest legos okay i find the best
legos and you're going to throw food at
me huh is that okay they come over mr
trump what are you doing here you're a
little [ __ ]
oh
god koi grab his legs cory grab his legs
ow mom okay who wants oh my god you
people are animals hey he started it
we'll keep you over the water with
growler i'm
i can't clap i want to clap to that song
but i can't because it'll blow out the
microphone it's true it's true it's it's
a clap worthy song though you should
know that it is a clown worthy i love
the law all right
i love outcast
you know on am radio we had a lot of by
the way uh wonderful affiliate we're
very grateful wkmq mississippi i said
missouri last week because i'm an idiot
that's all this it's all looking shut up
it looks like this treat our affiliates
nicely the letters look the same w e s
new hampshire wjc northern florida
patriot voices northern michigan klid
missouri
conan alaska wkmq missouri and of course
mississippi i didn't rewrite it on my
notes and of course wham detroit ann
arbor hello linda
she doesn't listen to this show she
never listens the people who started our
show don't even listen i don't even
think they like us they don't like us if
you like us then text me right now if
you like us text us
um
or tweet us at us crowder i don't have
that much time on my hands so
um you know what send an email yeah
let's just send an email send an email
to jared and then i'll get back to you
gosh there's so much that happened this
week
zuckerberg thinks we can fight isis
through love
um
it's true give me your money maybe you
can be volunteering for the front lines
the obamacare numbers uh the last the
town halls where's
how could they get any worse take a look
around you ellen we're at the threshold
of hell you know what else did you hear
about sarah palin's new show is there a
new one no no you haven't heard this no
syrupy
sarah palin's going to be like a judge
judy are you serious despite no legal
experience they're going to show up and
she is going to settle
right winging bitter klingon kitten i
cannot get a hallelujah ah that should
be i
that should be your thing that should be
your theme song at least that you know
in between commercials and stuff you
know i want to like sarah palin but she
makes it hard she doesn't want me to
like her she does not she doesn't want
you to like america well
obviously nobody wants you to like me me
america you are not an approval they
seek no
okay before we get to zuckerberg isis
we're going to have shapiro on next
because there's been a development in
donald trump michelle field situation i
know people are all on different sides
of that and i'll try and hold ben's feet
to the fire and get to the bottom of it
and see what the truth is um yeah listen
i'm not a trump guy and ben and i have
known each other for a long time i think
that this has been mishandled by by all
sides so we'll try and be fair but i
know many of you will will still [ __ ]
that it's not fair one thing i want to
talk about
before we get into all this this news is
the idea and you talked about this
justice versus equality is very
important i think a lot of people don't
just justice versus fairness justice
versus fairness because bernie sanders
now a lot of people don't realize he's
picking up a lot of steam he's gaining a
lot of ground on hillary is it likely
that he wins no
but he is doing far far better than
anybody predicted and that's on this
promise of fairness and distribution and
and getting your fair share people in
our generation really seem to place and
if you look at the pew research polls
place an emphasis on fairness
and
someone is someone is is why why is my
computer on right now no i guess uh i'll
i'll talk about this later my wife is
texting me during the show and she
should never be texting me during the
show she should always
stop unless she's saying that she likes
us no no that's enough for that the
email email
email it
um
fairness and justice aren't really the
same thing you know we talked about this
as a christian uh god is just but life
isn't fair and a lot of people say well
what do you mean by that listen i i
certainly think that as a society it is
much more
not much more important it's pivotal
that we place importance on justice not
fairness certainly not fairness of
outcomes that's what leftists
believe in promising let me give you an
example of justice versus equality
you're laughing because you know this i
know i know this is when i was a kid in
great in french canadian school okay
this is a true story and this is where i
learned as a kid that fairness is is and
political correctness is just it
corrodes the soul
uh mr elect was my teacher
must have been
second grade
and my dad worked for a company called
odessa i don't know what it is something
with cars
and one of the things is he had these
nice pens he had a bunch of pens odessa
and my dad's name was on the pens so he
opened up my my desk in my class and i
had a bunch of odessa pens and it said
you know darren crowder so i had those
and there was this kid i don't i don't
want her name named daniel cuffling we
became friends later on and he stole my
pens he took my pens as well where are
my pens and then i look over low and
behold daniel cuffling is writing with a
pen with my dad's name on it i go hey
that's my pen
no
i said come on it's clearly my pen my
dad's name that does your dad work for
an american company a desk is your dad's
last name crowder
and we got into a fight over it we were
yelling i escalated it
probably a little too quickly that's
just how i was and the teacher comes in
and says what's going on
and daniel says well he's he's yelling
and saying that i stole his pen i said
he did steal my pen and teacher goes
well
who's telling the truth i said i'm
telling the truth my dad's name is on
that pen there's five more pens that i
have with my dad's name on that pen you
can find them in his desk and the
teacher goes can you two work this out
with with your words without fighting
and i told the teacher i said i don't
need i don't need to work this out it's
not my it's your job as to is to make
sure that people stop stealing pens it's
i don't know if you notice it's a
problem here in your classroom
broken window theory let's fix the pens
before everyone starts getting their pen
stolen teacher goes well if you can't
work this out with words
nobody gets the pens and took them away
they had my dad's name on the pen
and his dad and my dad's company they
were clearly stolen pens and the teacher
said well well if you can't work it out
what's fair is nobody gets the pen now
that was fairness
but that was not justice and what does
that what does that tell you right
it places a lot more burden on the
person who's telling the truth on the
person who's not breaking the law when
you're doing whether it's someone
abusing welfare tweeting bitching about
how they need their fair share from
their smartphone while they have welfare
by the way if you're on welfare okay if
you're below and you're using it and
you're tweeting you should be put on
mute
i don't care what you have to say your
bitching is irrelevant
what does it do all daniel needed to say
is well it's my pen too because he knew
it was a lie and he knew it didn't
matter at that point
burden of proof was even though he knew
i was telling the truth
that's what that favors when you just
talk about fairness and feelings and
making sure that everybody leaves
feeling good the successful person the
person who didn't commit the wrong ends
up getting screwed this is a perfect
example it was my pen that was stolen
from my desk kid took it teacher saw my
dad's name in the penance in the name of
fairness
no one gets the pen
that's fairness that's leftism that's
not justice and that's something that
millennials need to understand that's
something that anyone out there needs to
understand fairness and justice are not
the same thing and when you play
identity politics and you play fairness
and you talk about fair share and you
throw it out without defining it it
inevitably favors the person who's
willing to gain the system
they're perfectly fine with screwing the
other guy as long as they gain from it
and i still never got that pen back
all right i think we have to go to a
break here so we have ben shapiro coming
on
at least he's calm we'll calm our nerves
we'll talk about the donald trump
michelle fields and him with the
breitbart situation and hopefully get to
the bottom of it
i don't know i'm no columbo but i think
i can handle this and figure it out stay
tuned
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar15.com oh there's another one
you got them thank god for ar15.com they
have ar-15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is on the web oh
no there's another one
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
this is breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm barry matheson we take you
live now to a public town hall with
governor and presidential candidate john
casick
now i'm really glad to be here still
running a positive campaign and uh want
to open the floor for for questions so
yes sir uh you
back there
you have a question
now now hey that's uncalled for you're
the same guy who was there in ohio wait
why why have you got security
hey over there security what what are
you doing
security
well now that just seems
counterproductive you're you're both
playing the same songs
you suck no no i would argue i i don't
i don't suck
suck john kasich well that's not really
a question could you phrase it in the
form of a question
you'll keep your brushes as town hall
unfolds for louder
that i want to do
all right so glad to bring on this next
guest we've had him before uh long time
colleague i guess we can say of mine
chief editor of dailywire.com you can
follow him at ben shapiro he is
somewhere
on his college tour right now i think
chap chapel hill when i asked ben before
the break he said i don't i don't know
chapel hill so you're getting ben
shapiro with half brain power today is
that fair to say
uh yeah i think i think that's pretty
fair which means that you know i'll take
on three lefties instead of six at a
time well yes yes that's that's pretty
much what i figured um okay so you have
had a couple of weeks i mean it's just a
whirlwind of your college speaking
uh obviously we can get right to it you
know we've talked about it on the
program we have guests from the other
side the michelle field incident donald
trump
um
firstly how are you feeling about this
because as someone who's been in the
conservative movement i guess since you
were what 17 very young syndicated
columnist
i get messages all the time and you know
this from top people who are going yeah
this is fractured friends family
what's it like right now for ben shapiro
i mean look
i'm used to receiving criticism but what
i'm not really used to receiving is
accusations of being a leftist because i
don't support a leftist like donald
trump that one's kind of new to me being
called a social justice warrior because
i don't think it's appropriate when a
campaign manager grabs and bruises a
woman's arm this is this is new stuff to
me it's so that that that i find you
know troubling and upsetting uh and you
know it's never fun looking at your
twitter mentions and you have thousands
and thousands of people calling you a
conservative and a and a social justice
warrior and photoshopping purple hair
and a nose ring on you and all that kind
of crap but you know like
i do find funny i do respect i thought
it
was
saying this is that he was more offended
by the purple hair than all the like the
the nazi anti-jew propaganda that didn't
even seem to bother him
yeah that doesn't bother me anymore that
you grow a thick skin with regard to the
nazi anti-jew crap after a few weeks of
this but the feminist photo shop that's
where ben has it that's where i draw the
line that's where i draw the line once
once they stick the the purple hair and
the nose ring on me i'm done i'm out but
it's so accurate too when i went to the
feminine film festival i was sitting
there going i i mean did they have a
convention before the convention to
agree on the outfits
you know you're around the same vendor
sits outside each one of those just
selling the same the kind of light
sticks and glow sticks
for the hair stuff
they do have a rule the rule is
non-conformity through conformity sort
of like the trumpkins rule which is
conservatism through non-conservatism
yeah i mean here's the one thing i will
say though i have more respect for
people like uh you know like milo friend
of ours who says listen it has nothing
to do with conservatism anymore i don't
really care about the principles behind
it people are mad and we want to see him
burn this down there are people who have
said that i understand that it's not my
belief but that's very different i think
from some of the mental gymnastics
required for people who claimed to be
christian conservatives fully agree with
this fully agree with this i mean when
milo says that he doesn't he doesn't
think conservatism you know has achieved
what its purpose was like just if you
want to admit who your man is and then
say you're voting for him because of who
he is or even if you're voting for him
because of who he isn't right he's not
the establishment so i don't want so i
want trump that's at least a fair
argument what i can't abide is the if
you oppose donald trump then it must be
because you're not a real conservative
who doesn't care about about the
constitution or conservative that's just
stupid i'm sorry it's just stupid and
and if you're going to defend trump on
the on the grounds that he's a decent
wonderful human being i think that's
equally stupid i don't think that he's a
decent wonderful hero i think some
people defend him on the grounds that
they like that he's an ass and that's
what i'm saying right which is fine
again exactly fine argument fine
argument he's an ass and you can you can
like him because of that yeah there's a
question is whether it also makes you an
ass but that's at least an argument it's
true well i think liking him because
he's an ass is fine i think people
liking him because they think he has a
backbone is entirely misled because i
don't think donald trump has met an
adversary um that he's really taken head
on so okay the michelle field situation
obviously you've caught a lot of flack
for this um this is happening this this
week right the video released and there
was
a couple things that need to be
clarified you're a lawyer so people need
to understand that um battery is
different from assault simple battery is
different from assault i've seen a lot
of sites use it interchangeably that
must frustrate you because it doesn't
help the case yes people are stupid also
felony battery is different than simple
battery demeanor battery is not the same
as felony battery people look up the law
in the state of florida all and all a
simple battery is an unwanted touching
that is intentionally performed that's
it that's the entire definition so
people who don't understand that i can
understand why they'd say and as someone
who has been at the receiving end of
full-on violent assault very different
we know we were on the phone when that
happened um i can understand people
saying oh this is exaggerated now i
think there are two components here
there's your opinion
on michelle field someone's opinion as
to whether it was exaggerated and there
is the law and what constitutes battery
and what was said so and then there's
the rails and then there's the real
story here which really has nothing to
do with michelle and has much more to do
with the trump campaign lying and
smearing her right that's that's really
the story here because the fact is if
corey lewandowski just says shouldn't
have done that my bad apologizes within
24 hours instead of going on twitter and
calling michelle iron an attention [ __ ]
then all of this is over immediately i
mean the reason she went and filed a
police report attention
he said attention seeker and all his
followers said attention [ __ ] uh
look when you say attention seeker about
a woman everybody knows what you're what
you're talking about essentially um and
and so you know he the idea here that
the the trump campaign was pushing is
that this was some sort of giant
conspiracy to get trump which if it was
it's the stupidest conspiracy in the
history of the world i mean your
conspiracy is that you're going to go
into a press room knowing that his
campaign manager is going to grab you by
the arm pull you back that you're going
to happen to bump into a reporter from
the washington post who saw the same
thing and that his campaign manager is
then going to deny it and trump is going
to deny it even though there are cameras
on them right that's that's that's your
giant conspiracy i mean what a
conspiracy it is i mean right boy it's
like it's like the jfk assassination
right but trump but trump people think
that's what this is i mean they're
watching this thing like the zapruder
tape going well you know originally the
case was she was never touched then the
case was well she was touched but not
that hard and now you got trump out
there like the like the utter adult that
he is i mean this is not a man with high
iq and you have him out there
he said everyone knows i have the my iq
is the best we'll bring up exactly he's
the best that's actually what he's doing
you know he has said that he also says
he has a very good brain which by the
way no one with a very good brain in
human history has ever said because it
makes you an idiot but donald trump says
about about michelle fields that you
know their [ __ ] she was holding the
secret service they were they were
bothered by it she was holding what was
it was it a pen was it a knife it could
have been a little bomb
yes donald i'm sure it was all of those
things you you bloviating sack of crap i
mean really
it was like a reporter holding a pen
what do you mean i think and the secret
service looks tremendously bothered by
all of this in the tape i mean it's not
like they have training in in dealing
with actual threats you need medal of
honor winner and normandy hero corey
lewandowski swooping in from behind to
save the republic by pulling michelle
fields four feet back the key word for
me again this is just the personal is
the from behind same thing with the
protester grabbing the caller from
behind he's looking at the protester and
the rally and uh nothing nothing nothing
guy reaches away and
he's looking he's looking at michelle
fields the whole time nothing nothing
nothing and then when she's turning away
that to me is like oh my gosh you know
just from a personal standpoint and
listen i'm i'm not i'm i'm a guy who
believes that women ought to be treated
differently than men you know if someone
did that to my wife that's different
than if somebody does that to me sure i
support the double standard
of course i support the double standard
because i don't think that women ought
to be treated physically the same way
that men are i'm not a feminist right i
don't have the purple hair so there's
something i've talked about this my wife
has swatted me on occasion not not but
like on the shoulder when i did
something really and i would never do it
to her and people so you knocked her
into the next room yeah exactly exactly
i'm just talking about this too like
women don't understand the difference i
was doing this you know i have i had the
surgery and i had the spinal cord injury
so i was doing these
like before the emg tests you know they
check they go okay curl against me and
press against me and this like old
filipino lady who was my neurologist
she's like oh you're very strong
what are we doing i could literally
shove you out the third story window
right now
how can you offer resistance and tell
um yeah
did you say did you say rindo you just
said rindo why because i was still in
the filipino ah okay we'll go with that
sorry so so one one so one of the things
that's been bothersome to me is the is
the failure to even recognize the basic
tax again you want to make the case that
that michelle made a bigger deal out of
this than it was i don't think that's
fair but that's at least a case you can
make if you want to make the case that
corey lundowski never touched her or
that he's some sort of hero for pulling
her away that's just stupid i'm sorry
are you saying the tape exonerates your
man no the tape shows exactly what
michelle michelle said it showed and by
the way she went silent for 24 hours
after this happened jimmy weinstein
tweeted but she went silent for for well
over 24 hours after this happened i
talked with her the night after it
happened and i encouraged her because of
all the flak she was getting to go file
a police report the next morning she
didn't she didn't want to it was only
after the trump people started pushing
her well if it's so real if it really
happened why don't you go file a police
report and try okay fine i will you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna say that
i'm faking bruises on myself and i'll go
ahead and do it i mean the whole the
whole thing is just it's the whole thing
is
to talking with ridiculous fields
tonight afterwards to start the rumor
that he had an affair
yeah there it is right and that's the
other one that i'm really enjoying is is
that the reason that i the reason i
haven't enough it's more than the
national acquirer head that's right i
mean personally ben shapiro slept with
me everyone report it oh absolutely come
on dude it was awesome and and the the
part of this that's so
ridiculous is that you know trump
actually goes out there and he
exaggerates what fields originally said
in order to claim that she exaggerated
it right right she never she never
claimed that she fell to the ground well
here's the thing i will say this i think
her claim the actor claim was i would
say slightly exaggerated however donald
trump absolutely and corey lewandowski
absolutely lied about her claim and they
lied about her not being there and not
meeting her and the only reason i say
that is because having
seriously faced violent assault having
been a part of it you know you see it
all the time whether someone shows up at
a college and kids yell and scream hate
speech and they classified as assault
and people build these things up like
right for me i've always tried to
mitigate it because i just want to do
comedy so i don't want to be a part of
that culture i'm not saying michelle
fields did it intentionally it didn't
look severe however you don't put your
hands on a reporter period and you
certainly don't grab a woman hard enough
to bruise her arm end of story i mean
grab yank bruce is fine for me legally
though can that be proven that the
bruises were from him
well i mean she she did go i mean the
only way that you can do it is well two
ways right i mean number one her
testimony right and number two
presumably they took a picture of her
and she told me they did that the police
took a picture of her arm theoretically
they could match that up maybe to his
hand size for example because you can
actually see finger imprints on her arm
and and also ben terrace of the
washington post actually in his report
says bruce has started to form on her
arm right so he actually says that he
saw the so that second witness testimony
and this is what everybody is is
this whole thing is bizarre yeah ben
terrace was conspiring with michelle
fields of breitbart right you're right
the breitbart reporter was deeply out to
get it was breitbart they were deeply
out to get donald trump i mean if you
viewed breitbart at any time in recent
history
this is probably the most absurd part of
the whole conspiracy theory is that
michelle was was as hired by breitbart
again breitbart was deeply out to get
donald trump right this isn't this isn't
jimmy carter jr i think actually
campaign if we're being fair um
breitbart i understand but i think
breitbart the man probably would have
been out to get donald trump oh are you
okay first of all i think breitbart the
man would have flown down to florida and
confronted lewandowski and trump about
this whole thing the day after i don't
think that they uh you know so this this
one again
people just say andrew now i just say
andrew andrew yeah i agree with you i
mean
one of the things that that's so
ridiculous is people are acting like
michelle originally claimed that corey
lewandowski grabbed a crowbar and hit
her in the head or something you know
what she claimed is that he grabbed her
pulled yanked her back pulled her toward
the ground she lost her balance
momentarily and regained it and then
when she said on megyn kelly's show i
think it was thursday night uh when she
said on megyn kelly's show that you know
this had been the worst trauma of her
life she didn't mean the physical no
stuff she meant she meant tr a a massive
national campaign coming after her and
trying to smear her as somebody who was
just making things up and and
in order to get donald trump like she
desperately needs the attention michelle
ended up quitting breitbart over this
and she doesn't have another job yet so
you know the idea that she was doing all
of this because she was desperate for
another job or because she wanted more
pay i mean there's a report today from
the blaze i've been pushing her to go on
tv and defend herself because trump is
again calling her a liar and presumably
an isis assassin with her magic pen bomb
and she and i've been i've been pushing
her it could be a detonator it could you
know you never know with those pens he
she could have brought him to a table
and done the joker trick from the dark
knight right maybe she's maybe she was
jason bourne it was born identity and
she was just going to start fighting him
with it with the pen right who knows he
could have been it could have been
anything but yeah i've been trying to
push her to do that she texted me late
last night she says here's the reason
i'm not and she and she listened to the
fair
affair and she she texted the to to the
blaze to an article from the blaze that
would that points out that she has now
had to abandon her apartment because
they accidentally published we have to
go to a break but i want to bring you
back ben shapiro daily caller
dillywire.com be back
welcome to cool news news with a super
cool approach i am your host phil cool
this week in the news
donald trump
ted cruz and john kasich had town halls
with cnn we've noted homosexual innocent
coop
hey p
peter man why isn't mike so close to
your face man huh
man you're chewing ice is distracting oh
i can't talk about the news i can't read
my copy if you're too nice
in a microphone
take the microphone away from your face
no
hey
hey b-ray
i'm talking you still drinking you still
chewing on ice be right
i'm gonna re-cop it i can't recap if
people can't hear reading copy if all
they hear you chewing that damn ice
i want you to take that ice
out your mouth
shut off the damn microphone let me read
my copy
no i'd be right
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s
crowder where i'm tweeting all day long
i'm ticking off the social justice
warriors you should see the amount of
hate i get on there far far far worse
than any fat sports illustrated model or
black lives matter charlatan so listen
it's free you get to be entertained and
you can chime in also if you're
following me on twitter you can send me
your tweets and maybe you'll be lucky
enough and i mean lucky enough because i
have a lot of followers okay that they
call me the follower machine to have
your tweet to me or not gay jared
included in a rockinest tweet of the
week so follow me on twitter at
s-crowder if not
i don't want to say i have sights on
your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
but you're a strange animal
oh glad to be back i apologize daily
wire a little safari there that's pretty
cool dailywire.com
our guest there's so many dailies ben
shapiro knows this he's a professional
he'll forgive me
he could sue me he's got the secret uh
establishment jew shekels
uh ben are you still with us
uh yeah i am yeah i don't know how to
deal with this you know we've all got i
i tell you what though i've never
experienced more um i guess i hate to
eat like anti-semitism in my life
and i'm not jewish no you're an honorary
jew now because you oppose trump that's
the way this is no it wasn't even the
trump just the israel thing like i
turned to jaren and i've turned to jared
several times ago like cause i you know
i i don't really get particularly
offended but i go man like
ah it's gotta be rough for a guy like
ben shapiro to literally go into his
timeline and see nazi propaganda that's
gotta it's at some point you gotta go
it's you know it it's it's certainly
annoying and i'm tired of hearing that
oh it's just us being pranksters you
know but there are certain things that
that really are not like when i can't
distinguish your tweets from david dukes
and that's not my fault that's your
fault right like if you tweet if you
tweet me like
an anti-semitic meme you're like yeah
i'm just being i'm just being a free
speech prankster first of all you know
do what you want i'm not saying the law
should come and get you i've never
called the cops on anybody because of
what they say but you know if
again if the open white supremacist and
your tweets are indistinguishable in
every way then how exactly i can't read
your mind and it doesn't sound very much
like i'd want to because i'm not sure
that there's anything there right
anti-semitism isn't really a fresh prank
though either i mean if we're gonna get
like down to something that's
really yeah it's been done it's been
done really well three thousand years of
the three thousand years of the mary
prankster ism later
some would say millions of jews uh
murdered was the apex of the prank yeah
yeah it's kind of old
i mean solid prank
that's one for them
that's one for them six years later all
the jews are gone boom what a prank i
mean but it's it's scoreboard amazing
scoreboard stormfront um yeah
you know
it's a weird
time to be here okay so we want to wrap
up the michelle the michelle fields
thing um
i think there's i think there's room for
people to be critical but like you said
if someone someone my problem is someone
can say well she exaggerated and the
arguments when i said are usually based
on the lie that she said she was thrown
to the ground which she didn't i mean
michelle fields regardless of one's feel
her statement never changed
that's right the way it was presented by
the way it was and by the way was backed
by ben terrace right i mean his report
in the washington post never changed
either but they called her a liar they
called him a liar he suggested that she
was after trump personally and that this
was all just made up but that's
brilliant though that's brilliant
because that is within the realm of
reason as people who have been long-term
conservatives you know that the media
can be out and they can target people
regardless of the truth and if you hear
the false claims not the actual claims
if you don't read the statements you can
believe well if she if she said she was
thrown to the ground and it's no
surprise that washington post would back
her up this isn't it's easy to buy in
well this is this is the part about the
trump campaign that i really find
despicable is they just put out these
waves of lies that are almost
undebunkable meaning because they're so
large so yesterday donald trump was on
msnbc and he actually said that michelle
fields was fired from breitbart okay
that's an outright lie it's an outright
lie he just makes things up i mean
he he's making up this whole story about
michelle was told twice by the secret
service not to touch trump you can watch
the tape okay it never happens it's just
that the whole thing is is really absurd
but because trump is lying all the time
and because his believers refuse to
believe that that he's lying even half
the time they just take what he's saying
for granted and he operates in as you
say in this in this very safe space for
him which is no matter what i say it
can't be debunked because the only
people who are there to debunk it are
the media you don't trust right trump
trump
trump is the wages of sin basically the
media has been horrible for 30 years and
so what you end up with is is a guy well
really 70 years and you end up with a
guy like trump who just says i'm going
to lie as openly and as blatantly as
possible and i'm going to dare you to
debunk me because no one trusts you i
don't know that he's pro i don't know
that he's proactively
lying just like he had never thought of
abortion i think he just says things and
refuses to apologize and then
if it happens to be untrue he has to
continue with it but i i generally agree
with you i do think however that when
he's saying that i think that these the
magical story about the pen bomb for
michelle is completely alive right i
mean he was there that's that's that's
natural why when he said yeah i was
deeply of you know she she assaulted me
which is the new claim i mean this is by
the by the way she came out to me okay
right okay in in donald trump's dreams
right in donald trump's dreams michelle
fields assaults him i mean i'm sorry but
it's not
for a man for a man who has mail order
brides i think that he he really ought
to he had to take a second look at how
he dreams that's true if i wanted a wife
like that i could buy one too if i
wanted boobs like that i could also buy
them it's not that impressive
it's amazing it's an amazing company i
actually think she seems she seems like
a decent woman i don't know i i the
whole wife thing it seems like
okay where do you think regardless of
what happens here by the way i don't i
don't you know whether she's a decent
woman or not the beginning of the
relationship was not particularly decent
if you read about no no of course not of
course not well
he was married at the time and she was
having an affair with him and she was
going on howard stern and talking in
extreme detail about their sex life
while posing nude on the cover of
magazines was this milan
or i thought that was
uh maples who talked about this oh no
melania too melania he was he was still
technically married to marlow when he
was when he was knocking on uh on
melania's door oh okay well i don't yeah
i don't know presumably at some point
there will be a fourth wife where he
upgrades and and you know has an affair
with her while he's married to this one
based on prior precedence well you know
i don't understand with the wife thing
regardless of where you line up
politically heidi cruz is an attractive
you know she's older than me but she's
an attractive older woman i don't i
don't get it like it's not a valid
insult that she's ugly well it's it's
it's not a valid insult anyway because i
mean if like what heidi cruz's looks
have to do with anything is beyond me
but it's but
trump it just he's such a he's just a
citizen i understand what they would
have to do with trump i mean listen you
it's not you have a very uh a very
pretty wife and it's all men like having
a pretty woman on their arm i understand
that i have a pretty yeah my wife's also
a doctor you know your wife actually
does things
no one cares about that no and that's
not required um
we we're almost out of this time for the
segment all right we have one minute ben
where do you think the republican party
goes from here
into the scrap people i mean
regardless no matter who it is almost
regardless if trump is deprived of the
nomination then he and his followers
walk out at least for four years we're
done if trump wins the nomination i
think that we're done for a generation
because he's just a smear across the
face of conservatism
yeah well that might be true but maybe
he can sell it to feminists as a pap
smear and they go well we're on board
with that so long as it's free bad next
planned parenthood you never know you
never know ben shapiro dailywire.com you
also have clavin over there a great
website i highly recommend it so ben uh
go get some rest but we want to have you
back as this stuff develops because we
don't have to censor you so thanks for
coming on brother sounds good appreciate
it be well louder with crowder everybody
uh stay tuned of course send your hate
mail not to me send it to ben
you can send the anti-semitic stuff to
either of us louder with crowder stay
tuned
and now it's time for your dating advice
minute
with bill cosby
now now this week's letter comes to us
from allen michigan from gainesville
okay jared says he has a problem with
his boyfriend no longer lusting after
him as he felt they did when they first
met
down the two can sound fun house over
two for one margarita nice
yeah what happens to the best of us
i will give you some advice
i don't know a whole lot about the two
jared and the gay character where's the
picture of the catcher and who's doing
the pudding
i don't know about that but i do know
how to help relationship advice
give yourself
some drugs and then you're gonna want to
get yourself some coffee maybe you like
the mocha the vanilla get yourself some
of the flavoring for covering up but
it's very important
you gotta remember that he cannot be
looking
when you put the drugs in his coffee
or you're gonna have a problem what you
do is maybe you say hey
i'm gonna make you some special coffee
it might be a good idea for you to maybe
first go through the plastic make the
pee pee and then you drug everything
you're gonna have to
this has been your dating advice minute
with bill cosby
you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body image not a
big human food market in detroit
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're getting louder with crowder
all right glad to be back second hour
ben shapiro was a great guest i am your
host again producing with me in studio
as always is
jared you can follow him at not gayjard
on twitter i fulfill my legal
obligations you can draw
your own conclusions
tim kennedy coming up at the bottom of
the hour here uh i need to set the stage
here a little bit for you
once i get my computer working the
interwebs is just a real problem gosh
you know you'd think they'd have enough
time to have perfected it
not so lucky this video went viral we
covered it at lotto with credit.com at
that point it it had only had
not a ton of plays
someone sent it to me by the way thank
you so much for people who send us
stories sometimes their best stories are
you know local things that we run that
nobody else carries
and um
people just send them to me and i go
well you know we should really write
about this and and it does really well
and other people pick it up so thank you
crowderheads for doing that this
happened at uh san francisco university
where else
i believe it's san francisco university
san francisco surprise i don't know
about san francisco college i don't know
you get you can get those things wrong
somewhere
where you legally have to pay for
someone else's
uh lorena bobbitted penis somewhere in
that vicinity
this happened so we were talking about
this earlier
and it's gone viral and a lot of people
just aren't aware as to how bad things
have gotten on college campus so jared
you can bring up my screen this woman
who you see
um the sideshow bob hairdo looking
character
is
for those listening terrestrially we're
doing this in the live stream i will try
and i will try and create this in the
theater of your mind to describe it for
you she's looking aggressively at this
white kid granted i look at him and i i
would like to you know stuff him in a
locker but that's not
it's not my right and someone behind
there who looks what would appear to be
a a gay inspector it looks like jesse
eisenberg had a baby with shaggy from
like scooby-doo doesn't it
dreadlock yeah yes yeah so this guy gets
stopped and this black woman who works
at the school starts berating him
why well i'll let you listen
do you know why he was in egyptian
culture are you egyptian
so here
okay you need to hear that she's saying
what you're doing is problematic he says
why she says because it's my culture
meaning his dreadlocks let me continue
do you know i was in egyptian culture
are you egyptian
are you egyptian no but doesn't matter
wait where's egypt
now she's grabbing him for those who are
listening terrestrially she's grabbing
him he's trying to remove himself from
the situation made a good point about
egyptian culture i didn't know that
about the about the dreadlocks in
egyptian culture
i thought it was nothing but scarabs and
billy zane
so she starts blocking him he's trying
to get away now she stops him this
employee
or someone who work or a school worker i
don't know what a campus worker means i
don't know if she's paid she stops him
to berate him for his hairdo claiming
that it's racially offensive he makes a
point that listen this does this goes
back to egypt
and then he tries to remove himself she
follows him blocks him and now she's
putting hands on him
starts mocking him and grabs his wrist
now she's grabbing his wrist and yanking
him back
so there you go now so that that's all
you need to see
she stopped
let me recap this for you okay
black woman stops white guy because he
has cornrows berates him for being
racially incensed for cultural
appropriation i'll explain that term to
you for those who don't know i know many
of you have jobs it's hard to keep up
he says this isn't even your culture
this is egyptian culture i'm not trying
to be offensive tries to remove himself
she blocks him she yanks him
and uh
yanks him back he tries to walk away
again she grabs him and he says yo don't
touch me and he
whacks on wax off to describe for people
listening to rest really to get her
hands off of him and then she complains
about him putting hands on her and the
gay inspector gadget white knight behind
her looking character says oh i can't
believe it
so here's the thing right it's kind of
like the pepper spray story that we'll
get to
um a pepper spray story that happened at
a trump rally
if you didn't see this video didn't
exist and this is most cases right in
the united states
the story would be
white student
assaults
female
black employee
and she would have made it a racial
thing and probably gone on the the talk
show circuit and said yeah it's really
hard to be a black woman on campus
you know what with us being put there
with all the quotas with our grades not
even being high enough it's really hard
we feel bad about ourselves
that would have been the story that you
you heard
kind of like the congressman clyburn
situation when andrew breitbart was
alive and he claimed he was called the
n-word and it didn't happen
there was more footage than you could
watch in a lifetime from every possible
angle it didn't happen this would have
been the story here without this
videotape she would have made the claim
local paper this kid probably would he
still may be expelled i don't know
similar to and we'll go to that let me
bring this up here
on my screen for those watching the
video cast and for those listening
terrestrially you can go see all of
these articles at lodwithcrowder.com
this is a parallel to a story that was
really viral where a girl
there we go
where a girl was at a trump rally and
she got pepper sprayed in the face and
so the headline was girl gets groped
gets pepper sprayed in the face well we
have videotape now this was bad all
around some trump fans were yelling the
n-word afterward and
she was clearly there and she assaulted
somebody nobody is right in this
situation but the media never said by
the way before the pepper spray she
sucker-punched an old man as hard as she
possibly could
it's kind of key if you leave it out
so that's why it's important keep your
cameras rolling all the time all the
time if you're not being taped now
assume you're being taped but please
keep your cameras rolling assuming
you're truthful
if you want to hide from the truth then
obviously you don't want cameras rolling
that's a great uh indicator of where
someone's character is if they want
transparency or if they don't
so this is so important for the oh
cultural appropriation now when was the
first time you heard about you've heard
about cultural appropriation not it's
probably been in the last year or so
actually yeah it's a fairly recent kind
of thing that's kind of
you see popping up more and more and
twitter and social media and that kind
of thing so it's for people who don't
know
it's another form of racism there are
you know racism at one point meant you
you hated people based on their skin
color you thought they were beneath you
solely based on their race
well that's not what it means anymore
can mean whatever leftist wanted to mean
depending on the day and where they are
in their hunger strike
and that also depends on how far into
their dad's trust fund they are i've
seen it
mizzou
miss you how do you pronounce it i've
always said it wrong i think i say it
wrong too i say mizzou i think it's misu
misu i said mitsu for a long time
because there was a french gang singer
that's incredibly wrong it is absolutely
wrong there's no doubt that i've said it
wrong
um cultural appropriation for those who
don't know let me just break it down for
you real quick i know a lot of you do
know but keep in mind that a lot of
people don't know it's this idea that
it's racist to absorb or use someone
else's culture we told you that story
where it was considered cultural
appropriation and racist for a frat
party to have a tequila
themed party and they had sombreros that
was considered cultural appropriation
and they were banned from public
gathering or speaking on the campus i
don't remember the punishment it was
ridiculous punishment in this case she's
saying it's racist it's cultural
appropriation because white people can't
wear cornrows a white guy wearing
cornrows is racist because only black
people are allowed to wear cornrows
if you can't see that that world view is
ironically incredibly racist i want you
to do me a favor i want you to right now
find your own quiet space where you can
take some time to think meditate if you
need to
and throw yourself off a rooftop i need
you to throw yourself off of a rooftop
if you believe that a white person
wearing cornrows is racist if you want
to compare that and these people do to
slavery if you want to compare that to
the civil rights struggle the only
productive thing you can do is throw
yourself off the roof now i know steven
just said i didn't say kill yourself
throw yourself off the roof there are
two very different things
that's cultural appropriation if that's
the case okay then you know black people
can't do a lot of things right um
friends seinfeld a lot of movies
right
you know i guess you got tyler perry
going on but there are a lot of things
out there that black americans take part
in that were created by white people
apple
iphones those things but we don't think
it's racist i know i know we're the
majority by the way cultural
appropriation really is kind of a
compliment
people don't you know what it means it
means people like some aspects that your
culture has to offer like hip-hop
remember how it was considered it was
considered such progress when hip-hop
hit the mainstream
even if you haven't seen that
documentary not the documentary but the
the auto i don't know if you call it a
biographical film on run dmc was it rum
dancer was it public enemy was run dmc i
think it run names run dmc
um
it was considered a breakthrough look
black americans are just as popular
they're outselling white americans and
you know what that proved
that people in the united states didn't
identify as a race didn't identify as a
tribe they identified as a set of ideals
and they were open to people of any race
or culture provided they were american
and they were contributing to american
culture it was considered a really good
thing
when people like run dmc or kids into
the stairs ll cool j uh flavor flav
obviously i know these aren't prime
examples my point is it was considered a
victory back then now that is considered
racism because white people would be
co-opting them you should apparently
feel guilty if you're a white person and
you like hip-hop let alone blues or rock
and roll or soul food in the united
states
apparently the appreciation of anyone
else's culture is considered racist
by the way you know who's a cultural
approach you know who's the worst
defender is beyonce
i was going to say the check
the jets are terrible but think of
beyonce
straight blonde hair
beyonce
queen bee
come on that's white people stuff
if i can't wear dreads i have no one i
have no one intend to wear dress but if
i can't wear dreads you can straighten
your hair and dye it blonde come on
that's not real
i don't think it's real i i don't know
beyonce could
could be real if she's potentially a
vampire there are rumors we can't
confirm them
yet louder with crowder we'll be back
after this
this week in cultural appropriation
um excuse me as somebody with white
privilege you cannot wear dreadlocks
okay um as a black person you can't wear
levi's
join us next week for more in cultural
appropriation
okay business time really simple some of
you don't know where to find me
louderwithcrowder.com half a dozen to
ten articles every single day twitter
follow me at s crowder louder with
crowder podcast on itunes soundcloud or
any other podcatching device youtube.com
stephencrowder or you can type in
stevencrowder on facebook and be one of
the million plus fans or join the
mailing list there are so many ways for
you to stay connected you have no excuse
you have no excuse just like you have no
excuse for those roles that are just
cascading over your belt buckle you
should be ashamed unless you're a lady
then you deserve get her a medal
oh
glad to be back
big story this week well we have tim
kennedy coming up next
gosh tim kennedy what did what a show
you're not plugged in i'm not plugged in
what do you mean i'm not plugged in what
are you talking about
i'm playing the wrong plugin
tim kennedy coming up next people who
don't know famous ufc fighter noted
conservative and uh
special forces bright guy not a guy you
want to anger
so it's good that we do this from a
distance it's true it's true he's not
he's i told him this on twitter once
he's lost the guy i want to meet
a dark alley
at least not on his side
right if you're a terrorist he's
probably the last guy you want to meet
well i don't want to disclose all my no
you don't want to do all your
affiliations but
there are a few prayer mats in your
closet somewhere yeah and this this uh
this bruce doesn't come for nothing
so mark zuckerberg uh arrogant
wienerface slash founder of facebook
guy's also a censorship maniac
does he just try to keep up keep up with
tim cook is that his deal with like
islam and stuff i don't what did tim
cook say something recently ah recently
he's always saying something
mostly steve jobs was pretty ignorant on
that as well oh it's true amy ain't
nothing but what vegetables and stuff no
it's a fruit fruitarian fruitarian
fruitarian is where you for a while
anyway fruitarian for those of you who
don't know is when you don't even eat
vegetables you only eat fruit that has
fallen from the tree because the tree
has willingly given you its fruit in
order to spread its seed and that's the
only way to live harmonious this is the
genius that produced the iphone yes
it's also the kind of crazy that has
freud shuffling papers in his grave
saying i i i don't even have a i don't
even have a fill out sheet for this
so the facebook founder said atrocities
in belgium pakistan and turkey were all
designed to sow seeds of hatred between
different communities
mark zuckerberg said each of these
attackers
were carried out with a goal to spread
fear and distrust and turn members of a
community against each other the only
sustainable way to fight back he said
against the sickening attacks is to
create a world where everyone feels
cared for and
loved well i guess mark zuckerberg i am
moved he has watched a lot of care bears
oh
yeah you know
logs i fighting terrorists
with hugs sixty percent of the time it
works
every time
this is proof okay this is proof this is
a case study
in the fact that someone can be
brilliant in one area and completely
inept in another
so if someone says hey
i am i don't know i'm a harvard lawyer
great it doesn't mean you want him
building your planes
if mark zuckerberg is brilliant probably
one of the most influential people of
the last century absolutely
doesn't mean he knows anything about
foreign policy
now something else this is a guy who has
attended censorship summits this is a
guy who was openly supported
removing people from facebook who have
dissenting viewpoints be it on the
refugee situation be it on far leftism
or if they believe in the second
amendment so it's important to note that
this is his worldview he's going to try
and create a world where people feel
loved
let me tell you something mark
i and i could be wrong i always leave
that on the table the possibility that
i'm wrong i don't think i am here
i don't think that isis would straighten
up and fly right um
because you sent them a pajamagram i
don't think
that terrorists are going to change
their way of thinking
if you're nice enough by the way
zuckerberg
you'd they'd probably go to town on you
a little bit longer because of your last
name
don't forget that
they're not going to make it quick and
painless for zuckerberg
okay
if isis if any of these people if they
capture someone with a berg or a steen
or shapiro they've hit the jackpot
and they're going to make that last and
they're going to videotape it
these are not people who are fighting
over economics these are not people who
are fighting over land these are people
who are fighting
because you don't s because you don't
submit to their religion
that's the only reason it's their only
stated reason it's why there will never
be peace between israel and hamas hamas
does not want
land
hamas wants the jews gone that's a part
of their charter that's a big thing i
know a lot of people who are new to
conservatism
you know it's popular to hate the jews
and so you throw israel under the bus
it's it's silly it's very unintelligent
it's not a war for example like
i don't know i'm trying like france and
england right it's not like that
hamas and israel their goal they're
tunneling in
they don't care if they reach a military
base or innocent civilians
any jew will do
that's the same mindset of isis
they don't care how nice you are and
this is a problem i mean
you want proof of this
the fact that attacks even occurred in
belgium
or france
or pakistan
the argument used to be well it's only
because the united states has been going
in there and invading and these this is
a retaliatory action belgium
france
these aren't bastions of of far right
wing neocons
these are the tolerant democratic
socialist to use bernie's term utopias
to whom the left has been pointing for
decades of how the united states is
supposed to be
and they got attacked
france twice
more frequently as a matter of fact
europe is is far more prone to terrorist
attacks in the united states are you
arguing that europe is less tolerant
they did what you wanted mark zuckerberg
you had a meeting with merkel
prime minister of germany and you you
both you set into a live microphone
zuckerberg said into a live microphone
that yeah listen we'll do we'll make
sure that these anti-syrian refugee
stuff we'll make sure to prune that from
facebook and a live microphone said
we're going to remove this we're only
going to keep one point of view in
people's news feed well guess what
more refugees in germany
also a lot more rape
violence terrorism economic problems the
citizens aren't happy now you have a
rise of a far right-wing nationalist uh
uh movement
it's just it's just so silly these are
people who don't live in reality again
that goes back to the world view of
federalism constitutionalism
conservatism free enterprise versus
socialism centralized power at some
point you have to account for human
nature at some point you have to accept
do you believe that evil exists
i do
and i would file isis
under that column
i could be an ignorant american slash
canadian depending on how mad you are at
me that day but i think it stands to
reason tim kennedy next
cultural appropriation
um excuse me as
some whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar15.com oh there's another one
you got them thank god for ar15.com they
have ar-15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is in the web oh
no there's another one
you got him yeah with your what ar15
from where yeah
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
an earthquake warning is in effect if it
is mild find a doorway if it's a stage
four or higher find an open area if it's
a stage six
[ __ ]
all right we are back and i was doing
some things on the interwebs during the
break and so i'm i'm trying to finish it
up i think not gay jared do we have the
next guest
we do he is he is there he is there
don't say anything
don't say anything this next guest of
course ufc fighter uh former special
forces he's been on i think history
history channel is your channel haunting
hitler hunting hitler great show and um
he's also uh he's also a uh
he has he has a penis he's a man bona
fide badass well you have to i i believe
his preferred gender pronouns are
masculine tim kennedy are you with us
sir
yes i am oh good lord look at that he
has the full count of monte cristo going
on now
yeah
for those who are who are listening
terrestrially he has a full beard and
face thing going on i don't know how i
feel about it
well uh i think it signifies the
anti-establishment a little bit you know
it's kind of
i want to blow up parliament
but still i'm here to party yeah well
but i also like to party remember
remember the fourth of november was it
fourth of november fifth in november
fifth of november i don't know
i thought it was a crappy film it was so
i don't think it's that bad i think it's
pretty good actually no i don't know
well we're talking about v for vendors
so tim kennedy is back gosh tim kennedy
okay there's a lot going on right now
and you've talked a lot on twitter and
you get you get a lot of flack you've
sort of waited into politics more you're
big on this the problem with the
emasculation of the united states and i
think that you have a leg to stand on
with that
why do you think why do you think it's
important i know listen you're an
intellectual two people are going to
think well he wants all guys to fight no
no that's not it and so i want to give
you the floor
um
yeah i i think it's just like the
the current state of where we are as a
society has become more and more
pathetic
we just we've lost sight of who we were
uh where we came from
and how we could continue to be the most
successful and powerful nation on the
planet right
that that will not exist when we have
safe zones and
um trigger words and i love how out of
touch he is that he has them just it's
safe spaces and trigger warnings and you
triggered me by not even getting it
correct this is off to a horrible start
so you're like wow
jeez words matter tim
i'm actually glad i don't have it right
i i think it would be i know
that's a testament to how
uh that's what my dad will do he'll
deliberately say justin bieber just
because he wants to disassociate himself
with such horrendous uh human activity
but yeah well yeah i mean it it is
pretty incredible and we were just
talking about this you did you see the
mandatory sensitivity training now
coming to the marines
no i know i missed that entirely uh well
basically it's mandatory you know hr uh
training where you can't see people you
can't see race or gender any of those
things but of course the pt requirements
have to be lowered so women can be on
the front lines so um i think like on
campus we expect it but now it's seeping
into the military
have you noticed that absolutely
from
ranger school to special forces odas uh
civil affairs
uh psychops like all all of these
different
what we're very specialized
units are now going to have to not not
try to make it happen and they're going
to have to
figure out how to accommodate women
coming into those units right i'm 100
for women in combat i'm all about it i'm
not you're not no
yeah that's that's fine um i'm okay
disagreeing with you uh i think how dare
you this is my show you come in my house
and you talk this kind of trash
who is taking care of the booking these
days all right go ahead
they uh
it just can't be done by lowering
standards you you said it you know like
they're coming to the marines but
they're gonna lower stuff okay so that's
a roundabout way of saying no because
there are not many women that you have
very few women who can meet those
standards that's right but if they can
then they deserve to be there that's
true although we did have someone who
was a sergeant in the marines catherine
sergeant catherine come on and she she
is very much against it she said because
it would change the dynamic in mixed uh
mixed squads she said people would
inherent men would inherently feel more
protective of them they would treat them
in a way they wouldn't treat men this
was a woman who said this which was
honestly something i hadn't even thought
of before beyond the physical
and she's absolutely correct it would
change the chemistry of any unit any
platoon any squad any oda
um but we i don't know if that's gonna
be for the worse and we're not gonna
know
um until it's done we know that it's
been successfully done in israel for
instance
um
and uh those their combat units that are
have mixed gender are very
efficient
so
okay
well maybe maybe you're right i don't
know i i have no idea you know it's
different across israel we did have a
study up there we talked with mark
reporter where it did show that the
mixed mixed squads were definitively
less uh less efficient
yeah less successful but you know listen
i don't hold it against him because they
smell better and they look better and
you don't hate women you married one
i did
yeah i like them
that's the takeaway for today's show
okay so you before you tweeted out think
of who could be president
this time next year and then consider
killing yourself and people got mad now
who are you talking about because i
obviously don't like the left but last
time you were on i think you said you
weren't really thrilled with anyone in
the republican party either yeah yeah no
no i i was talking about
so let's just take the number one and
number two we have trump and hillary uh
so
while we have an egotistical
narcissistic
you know
possibly pretty corrupt business guy
and then well i think to be a felon a
criminal you know borderline on
lying murder
as a secretary of state
as our other option those are our two
options so well i don't know that you it
seems this week that trump may not get
the nomination
yeah
which would do which would mean what
that we're going to give it to ted cruz
yeah
it seems like that between the two do
you have a pick
no no i don't like it
well okay well why don't you why don't
you like you just we obviously know you
don't like donald trump but why don't
you like te who was your person in this
race i guess who was your was it rand
paul
yeah i mean i had
although rand paul's you know foreign
policy was a disaster you know he and
his father um just seem to not
understand that
um the kind of one
significant thing that the government
needs to do is right have a strong
deterrent presence in the military and
they're like i don't know we'll just
we'll just shrink everything to include
all forms of government including the
military um that's bad plan right bad
plan okay so who was your person then
of that of our current options no of of
in the whole primary i mean there there
were like 42 people
see this isn't fair you can't just say
you don't like them and not pick anybody
damn
i don't like any of them i'll take brian
stan nick palmiciano um
i'll take uh well brian stan liked jeb
and he he came out and he got a lot of
flak because he doesn't like trump
yeah i don't i don't like jeb no
all right so you don't like trump or
hillary it's possible that it comes down
to bernie versus
cruz i mean these are possibilities the
likelihood is hillary trump but this
week has been a rough rough week for
trump um yeah so wha
what is that so what do you think of the
republican party then you're someone
who's been in the military or someone
who's been politically outspoken if
you're at this point is it beyond uh
repair
no no it's not beyond
well first i hate the two-party system
so the fact that we have to limit this
to the republican or democratic party is
asinine
i think that if everybody kind of
understood what a libertarian is uh we'd
have like an entire third party but
everybody has no idea of how to
categorize themselves so they just end
up saying i'm one of those two
horrible options that have two horrible
nominations right um
so the problem with that though is i
mean i understand it but the two-party
system is is is closer
to perfect than like a parliamentary
system and i said because in canada you
can have a guy who wins with 30 of the
vote
and that's kind of why we have the
electoral college right trump has that
ceiling of 30 percent
and some people would argue you know
broker convention contested convention
there's there's some murky rules there
but
some people can argue well a guy doesn't
get over that 30 hump should he really
represent the whole republican party
just because it's been fractured so the
two-party system isn't good but if you
kind of see what's happening with
republican primaries how no one can even
get half the vote that's what happens in
a system with more than two parties in a
general so that's not good either
you know like
scary you know we're
i'm just depressing you i'm depressing
tim kennedy yeah it's 2016 and we're
moving very quickly to the nominated
nominee and uh we are in a disarray and
you know what i what would be a horrible
idea is the
at the convention they're like you know
what ted cruz is he's too too he's too
conservative he's too
libertarian he's too tea party-ish so
we're not even going to give him the
nomination we're going to go with like a
paul ryan or
somebody else that's even more
establishment just because they're going
to play by the rules and now i don't
think they can do that now i don't think
there's any way they can do it i don't
think they would i think they could do
whatever they want they're playing
they're playing their own instruments
you know they're dictating how this
entire race is going
well not right now that's why they're
russian that's why they're scrambling
and all hands on deck you know with the
with the the fire department with trump
and cruz i mean they they absolutely
hate cruz
and then they just
trump is too much of a wild card so they
they don't know what to do but i think
at this point they realize the
republican party has no chance if it's
anyone other than those two um but you
may be right they may be so out of touch
they bring out paul ryan with his p90x
shorts you know listen he's got you ever
seen that picture
yeah it's special
i'm not gonna throw stones at wearing
short dudes that wear short shorts
because i wear short shorts i'm wearing
short shorts right now well that's fine
but yeah but you've earned the right oh
gosh those aren't shorts
those aren't i don't think those qualify
as shorts for people listening yeah
they're they're ranger panties they
definitely your wife is missing some
clothing
no doubt
yeah you're not supposed to panty raid
your your wife tim that's not how it
works it happens in college dorms so uh
yeah i don't if they bring out paul ryan
listen i'll urinate on the ashes of the
gop i've talked about that i don't hate
paul ryan but that would be a real slap
in the face so um
donald trump doesn't get the nomination
they give it to ted cruz well they don't
give it here's what i think the only
fair way is if no one has the delegates
at that point and you tell me you think
i'm off base here if no one has the
delegates needed at that point they say
okay let's take it to a head to head
naturally that's trump versus cruz and
then at that point when it's just trump
and cruz
all the delegates can be re-pledged
because they're no longer going to rubio
kasich whoever else and you pick in the
head-to-head who wins between the two of
those i think that's the only fair way
if someone doesn't have the delegates by
the time we get there does it sound
reasonable
yeah
okay so if they did that and it ended up
being cruz
would you go for them
yes okay uh you end up being trump would
you vote for him
yes
well that's hillary's that is if hillary
is the other nomination because i hate
her what if it's bernie
if it was bernie sanders the thought
that i would vote for a socialist um
well if it was bernie versus hillary i'd
vote for bernie think about that for a
second i don't want to
why would you why would you force my
mind to go to such a dark place this is
entirely unnecessary on this program
bernie versus hillary i tell you what
though people have really underestimated
him people aren't afraid of socialism
anymore and they they say this a lot and
you you touching this earlier we did a
video on this just released today
leftists say well you think you don't
like socialism well the military that's
socialism
it's so asinine because as you said
legit there's a legitimate role for
government and is there any more
legitimate role in the military
no
i'm trying to think i can't think of any
i don't know maybe more military
i'm not entirely sure okay let's let's
switch it when are you gonna get a fight
in ufc for those listening he's a ufc
fighter
when am i gonna get a fight yeah when
are you gonna fight in ufc next oh so
you know i got back um and available for
a fight
like a month ago i had a deployment um a
special force thing you you also
introduced me as a former green beret i
don't even know what that means that
folks i didn't say green beret i said
special forces because i didn't want to
get it wrong okay that former part never
say again i will cry i'll climb through
the screen
that looked like the cover to a horror
vhs
it's just a beard and an eye
yeah
okay sorry
available for a fight
april may
june give me anything um so you do want
to fight me
no well i asked anderson silva i asked
for vitor belfort i asked for get guard
mousasi so i'm ranked um now seven
because michael bisping got ranked above
me and though even anderson silva came
in and lost michael bisping
uh they are now both ranked ahead of me
well it's a weird it's a weird ranking
we'll talk about that more when we come
back and there was something else we
were going to talk about but tim kennedy
after this music you hear then
commercial and then more tim kennedy in
short shorts ladder with crowder stay
tuned
this is breaking news on laurelwood's
crawler i'm perry matheson we take you
now live to the donald trump cub scout
camping trip as he stops amidst his
campaign in wisconsin
okay everyone gather around the fire i
got a really scary one for you okay look
see the flashlight on my face you're
shining up okay it's just an op it's
what we call an optical illusion okay
it's not real i'm not a monster okay i
tell good i tell scary stories i tell
such good series they frankly they call
me the scary storytelling machine okay i
would never call myself that that's what
they called me
okay what's that up there i think it's a
spurs mr trump okay let me get back to
telling the story okay truthfully
it was a dark and scary night okay such
a scary night the best the scariest
i thought they got to shut up don't
worry about it mr trump i want to hear
the story yeah yeah
all right okay frankly
it was storming okay it was raining so
much it was raining like dogs it was
raining cats and dogs even both cats and
dogs i'll catch it
mr trump the bald eagle is endangered
that's a federal crime okay he started
it
we'll keep you arrested with crowder i'm
we will party hard
all right
i'm hearing an echo we are back sorry
for those watching the video live stream
apparently it went down we had some
problems we are back with current
special forces uh i don't know what you
call them i don't want a special forces
guy ufc fighter host of was it killing
hitler hunting him hunting hitler tim
kennedy i got that so wrong tim sorry
about that that's right hunting hitler
or killing hillary would have been a way
better um show and i would have enjoyed
it more well i think bill o'reilly has a
lockdown on killing anything he just
needs the next book so i think killing
him
the queue it's gonna be killing it
killing kennedy killing i mean killing
o'reilly is going to be in there at some
point that's when he wants to do the
andy kaufman so okay you're talking
about the fighting ufc fights for a lot
of people out there don't necessarily
follow this um
yeah i know you're ranked now behind
bisping and silva um and you beat you
beat the brakes off bisping to be fair
but i'm sure you you can accept that
some of that is due to inactivity
yeah um absolutely except that
how anybody could think i would lose to
michael bisping now even though i've
already beaten him beaten him and i've
gotten better
or to anderson silva who stylistically
is i would be the worst matchup i think
in the entire division for him so
um i don't think rankings are based on
that though
just as far as the numbers
yeah well i don't think they are i think
it's just number there's you know it's
an algorithmic thing i think if you got
in there and mix it up with just a
couple of people you you'd probably
right at the top if you fought either of
them but they're not the ufc is not
willing to offer you either those fights
no no no no no no no yeah no they
they're gonna they're gonna wait until i
know i have another tv show or something
else and then they're gonna offer me a
fight and i'm gonna be in like brazil or
africa or something um or they know i
have a deployment coming up and then
they'll offer me a fight against like a
friend of mine or something like that
have they offered you any low level
fights
like fights that wouldn't make sense or
has there just been have there just been
no offers
no the only the only fight that i had
was against a friend of mine who is
ranked
uh way below me um and it's like the
only guy in the entire division that has
been a teammate for the past six years
because you don't have many friends
yeah no
well now you just trash these half half
the rankings but i do i think you would
do pretty well um
in any of those fights and yeah you've
got you've got a really interesting
division right now i wanted to talk with
you about this i think this kind of ties
into the macro we've been talking about
you know freedom of the press the ufc is
an entertainment organization but have
you been following the firing of ariel
helwani there from fox no oh you didn't
know that
no yeah he was fired
for what
well he said people he was very classy
about it for those of you who don't know
he's basically the howard cosell of mma
ariel helwani i actually know him
because funny enough i met him at a
jujitsu gym when i was in living in new
york and he came in and no at this point
no one knew who he was you're all he's
been covering mixed martial arts this
sport for a long time a lot of you would
be surprised at how reasonable he is
with politics too coming from montreal
and he covered the ufc back when nobody
did he has the biggest mma program and
he worked on fox for a while well the
rumors were and he didn't shut them down
he was very diplomatic about it was that
as some fighters are leaving the ufc
right now and he was covering like rory
mcdonald and and benson anderson the
free agency and he did say he they fox
called him with a two-minute phone call
and said you're gone so he's gone he's
not covering any ufc events now um under
the fox contract how did you not know
this this happened like last week
uh i have been um have you like seen my
instagram or anything in the past couple
of weeks i haven't because i want to
avoid the pictures of the short shorts
okay uh there are no pictures of short
shorts but i've pretty much been either
in the woods or on the side of a
helicopter okay um so i've been kind of
disconnected and i'll
when i get wi-fi i'll send my wife a
photo and be like hey throw this on a
social media of some form um so yeah
i've been missing i've been out entirely
i'll just
well just hearing that at your first gut
overreaction i mean what do you think
about that you've had a good
relationship with ariel right it's been
fine no no no we actually started um
very caustic he and i were i wouldn't
say like enemies but i hated him uh he
he asked very pointed direct questions
like a good journalist should and he
would try to not get a catch out of you
but he likes to stir the pot
yeah yes absolutely and i was cutting
weight one time and i was just being a
dick
um
and and i was a dick to him and then
that's what i remembered so for like a
year i was like dude i hate this dude um
and over the course of like the past
four years um just watching him and
reading him and seeing how he is as a
journalist i i had
what ended up being like a profound
um did you apologize i did i apologize
perfume you did the opposite of the
trump you were willing to apologize
yeah um i so i apologize actually wrote
him as well and i said man listen i was
so far off base um and and i'm very
sorry uh you're kick-ass journalist and
um
you know please forgive me so now we're
good was he gracious
what were they gracious about it
yeah yeah you do such a classy dude so i
have so
um
one it sucks when you realize that you
you're completely wrong and you're an
[ __ ] like i was uh but now
i'm not looking at him through rose
colored lenses i think i have an
objective perspective about him as a
journalist yeah and he is one hell of a
journalist he's very good
yes he really is which is rare in the
sport
like
yeah it's well it's tough because you
get your credentials denied and um a lot
of people used to say he was a ufc shill
but he's been very fair in his coverage
and he hasn't thrown anybody under the
bus but i thought you might have some
opinions on that because of like you
said the journalism and mma is very
controlled and it's a private
organization they have the right to do
that
unlike the the national football league
you know it's not really a sports
organization it's an entertainment
organization but i just
go ahead this isn't anything new if you
go to look loretta hunt who writes for
espn right um she she had
uh she wrote a negative article about
careful on repeating what the president
said this is fcc monitored yeah um so
she said something not nice and
uh she got excluded from any future ufc
events so for the for the company that
she worked for that was pretty much a
requirement because she was covering the
ufc so now she's ex-communicator
ostracide from the mma community jeremy
botter another example of that that just
happened recently so now he's over at
flow sports he's going to be doing
amazing things for wrestling and jiu
jitsu and all other combative combat
kind of sports right uh but you know
arie holani to me that's like the icing
on cake that is that is that final candy
he is well he's the the thing is it's
changed now whereas he might have been
voiceless once now he has far more reach
than a lot of traditional media and i
think that's a big mistake same thing in
the elections traditional media they've
overestimated their power and we're
seeing that tip i wanted to wrap it up
because we have to let you go tim
kennedy best place for people to find
you real quick
uh
tim kennedy mma on instagram infinity
mla on twitter and tim kennedy on
facebook and he wears short shorts
ladder with crowder stay tuned
this is breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm perry motherson we take you
live now to a public town hall with
governor and presidential candidate john
keysuck
listen i i i can't answer your questions
with the two stereos okay it's it's just
trap
thank you now sir if you shut yours off
i will
i'll do my best to answer your question
and try and be productive okay yeah why
did you eat your pizza in new york with
a fork now why is everyone asking
about pizza with a fork it's not that
big of a deal i guess not if you suck
okay enough of that the pizza was hot oh
nice guy's mad no i am i i am not mad i
am not going to take the low
mother [ __ ]
we'll keep you abreast as town hall
unfolds for louder with crowder i'm hari
mahogan
you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body in it not a
big human food market in detroit
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're a strange animal
you're getting louder
glad to be back third hour we're going
to have courtney with us uh after this
we just had tim kennedy i know some
people get mad if we talk about things
that aren't political like the fighting
with tim kennedy but that's his life
listen i think he's an army ranger
or paratrooper i'm not entirely sure
that's why i say special force yeah
sniper or something like that something
like that something
really cool not someone you want to
anger no but uh he's also obviously a
noted conservative very strong on on
military and foreign policy but the
guy's also a fighter that's how he makes
a living and uh and you know he should
go out and support guys guys like that
tim kennedy i should should guy has
influence in a sphere outside of
politics but
i wanted to talk about something we were
talking about this this week where we
wrote an article up at
lotterycrowder.com uh courtney helped me
write this that not all religions are
the same
and it was written to leftists
who of course try and
you've heard that argument right
religion destroys religion is the start
of all wars oh yeah yeah every every
root of all evils
and it's just not true it's a great
bumper sticker though it's a greedy it's
a great bumper story catch is not
actually right next to the darwin fish
oh yeah and i love those people they
have the co-exist peaceful and the
darwin fish it's like listen i'm not
saying that you're wrong with the darwin
fish i'm not arguing with you against
evolution that's not what i'm doing what
i'm saying is that you're demanding
people coexist and be peaceful
immediately followed by an incendiary
bumper sticker
you're culturally appropriating the
christian fish by the way that cr if
you're talking about appropriation it's
not like dreadlocks okay it's not like
hip-hop music we're something that
cultures like the reasons christians
drew that fish was as a secret code so
they didn't die
and you're appropriating it just
something to think about so there's this
argument that religion is the cause of
all wars um no
now of course if that were the case you
wouldn't have had tribesmen warring
people were over a lot of things they
wore over power they wore over land they
wore over riches
um
and by the way it doesn't even have to
be religion it can be any ideology
that's important for people to know
because there's an argument that's used
a lot and this is why we wrote let me
first start of the premise of the
article before we get to that
of all the religions there's one that
causes a lot of problems okay there's
one that needs a time out in 2016 and
it's islam
i am a christian i don't try and
proselytize all the time i'm not on here
to convert anybody i'm not a i'm not the
perfect example i talk about that i'm
open about that i'm also open about my
faith however i don't fear imminent
decapitation from buddhists or hindus or
taoists or
scientologists
okay jehovah's witnesses yes they're
annoying i get it they're very annoying
on a weekend when i don't want to have
to put on pants and answer the door that
being said it's a small price to pay
compared to being decapitated simply for
not submitting to a religion of all the
religions in the world you can argue
that they're all wrong but yours and by
the way you should argue that when
people say well who are you to think
that your religion is right
if you don't think your religion is
right if you don't think your faith is
right why
why
why bother why bother it's kind of like
my parents used to say when i was a kid
well you just always think you're right
stephen
yes
otherwise why would i think it
why would you act on something if you
thought what would i why would i have an
opinion if i thought what am i going to
be wrong opinion that i think is wrong
i'm going to hold the fastest really
wrong it doesn't mean that i can't be
wrong
but naturally everyone's going to think
they're right until proven wrong and
then you concede that territory i don't
understand that you always think you're
right
yeah i guess that sounds about that
sounds about correct
islam is the one that is blowing up
people in record numbers islam is the
one that can't play nice with anybody
else it's kind of like one of those fish
tanks you have all of those different
fish and you can have your guppies you
can have your goldfish but then you have
those little fish that look like they
have the
the
the cirque du soleil sashes as they swim
through and they eat all the other fish
it doesn't matter if all the other fish
want peace that one's going to eat the
other fish and it happens
that happens anyone who screwed up with
a fish tank i did that as a kid
lesson learned
i don't even know a lot about fish i
know if they have the floaty sash
looking
fins best to avoid
just because there's a chance i know
there's a chance they're a good one
same thing with islam right now same
thing with the refugees i can't know so
i put a ban on my fish tank on all the
fish with the cheeks and the things that
look like olympic ribbons
islam is the one religion that is a
problem and leftists want to throw them
all in and they like to appease islam
because of course political correctness
is um
basically the people killed in the in
in terrorist attacks are sacrifices from
the left at the altar of political
correctness that's where we've gotten to
say that we didn't know we couldn't see
this coming we had no clue
oh my gosh no it's it's not like a
school shooting where people had no idea
some guy went nuts like the kalamazoo
shooter where people legitimately had no
idea he thought satan was talking to him
through his uber app
they can say we did not see this coming
you can't say that with a guy who joins
isis he can't say that with a guy who
says maybe sharia law
so that's the point of the article we
need to be honest about that not all
religions are the same now we get these
responses religion are the cause of all
wars a lot of people say that no that's
not true again ideology people can war
over even if they're atheists now am i
saying that all atheists are responsible
for mao and pol pot you know of course
more deaths in modern history than
religion no i'm not i'm not laying at
that at the feet of all atheists
but those were people killed in the name
of an ideology
atheism
we've written about this on the site the
recent video on democratic socialism
lenin said that atheist propaganda was
necessary for communism it was a part of
the ideology atheism and communism is a
distinctly atheist ideology i'm not
blaming atheists for the violence
just like you don't need to blame
christians for the violence if the
united states for example is at war with
iraq
however
that is different you can blame the
violence on an ideology that expressly
calls across the board for violence and
people are following that in record
numbers that's islam
another thing people were sending me and
you probably saw this jared people
saying well religion doesn't create
anything it only destroys there's
nothing good to come from religion i'm
trying to speak in only the physical
sense here that's completely untrue
what we have as far as modern history
right history as we know it human
civilization
goes back about 10 000 years
boom everything bloomed we kind of had
cavemen repeat and then modern history
where we have documented records we know
a lot you're looking back about 10 000
years
and if you want to talk about an
incredible boom it comes with modern
with with judaism modern christianity
after christianity and by the way not
growing at the same rate as other
countries that is important you may be
an atheist that's fine
there are ideologies that lend
themselves to
growing innovating more the pantheistic
religions of the native americans they
didn't create anything they were here by
the time the settlers got here after the
greeks after the roman empire after the
ottoman empire they were here after that
and they didn't have the wheel
there are places right now that are
still uh
panty you know they worship many gods
well why is that the way because the god
of the water makes it that way why is
this happening well that's because of
the god of the truth they don't know
photosynthesis there's no reason to go
forward and explore that's not the way
christianity was created that's why you
look at the boom in modern science
also some things to note
um and i know a lot of people doesn't
have anything to do with christianity
historically you can look and correlate
it with this wonderful empire known as
china that is true china made some
brilliant advances in technology
but if you then compare it to christian
nations afterward
big difference look at where china is
now where the united states is now at
some point you can only make so many
fireworks and giant dragon parades and
we say okay
we get it but what else do you have on
your deck of cards but they're really
cool they are really good they're really
cool and the chinese fireworks are the
best fireworks we used to see the
international fireworks show so again
that's important to note
there is val whether you're an atheist
or not you can't deny historical value
just like i can't deny the historical
value of islam as far as architecture
they haven't really done a lot for human
rights civil rights they haven't
advanced that way historically islam is
not responsible for a lot of judicial
practices or systems of law that any
person in the modern world would be
proud of i do think that as a christian
one can be proud of the constitution
which was expressly created around the
central tenets of the christian faith
something else there are certain virtues
people say well if you're a you you're
only doing this because of some pie in
the sky fantasy because of god you're a
horrible person that's an argument from
atheists a lot this is all in response
to the column i have it right here why
don't you do it because it's the right
thing to do i understand that and
there's validity to that
i don't believe every atheist is a bad
person i don't believe that i know a lot
of atheists who are very good people who
want to do what is ethically correct
what is morally correct okay i
acknowledge that but you also have to
understand
that some of these virtues we now hold
to be self-evident weren't at all
before modern christendom for example
compassion was not considered a virtue
look at all of these greek philosophers
look at look at some of the great
philosophers look at some of the great
leaders historically compassion was seen
as a weakness
it was not seen as a virtue that came
with christendom
and you can see that with again china
as the world developed as human
development exploded
so that is important for people to know
listen you don't have to be a christian
we don't have to agree on faith you may
think it's entirely imaginary and you
may i have to leave room for the fact
that you may be correct but in a purely
physical sense it is inaccurate to say
religion is the cause of all wars
religion hasn't created anything it's
only destroyed and it's very
intellectually dishonest assuming you've
read up on any religion at all assuming
you've read your quran even five pages
in any direction it's woefully
intellectually disingenuous to say well
islam is is christianity is no better
than islam
it's simply false it's verifiably false
you can observe it through
mountains of data more than you could
ever see in your lifetime more than you
could ever read in your lifetime so i
think it's important to make that
argument again i'm not someone going out
there i'm not a christian apologist i'm
not a historian but courtney and i did
write this article
and uh it went up and and there were a
lot of reactions and i think that a lot
of people just buy this wholesale
because they believe what their
professors tell them
and uh and they don't do a little bit of
digging for themselves it's not to say
that there haven't been some horrible
acts committed in the name of many
religions
the difference is
islam historically has been spread
through violence and the sword and there
haven't really been moments of peace
globally with islam it's just not the
case and today right now living in
reality
islam is the problem
there is not the same kind of
destructive force
okay at work here
with hinduism or christian it's islam
sorry if that's not nice we'll be right
back
this week in cultural appropriation
oh excuse me sir um yeah that's actually
really offensive uh perpetuating a
negative mexican stereotype you should
do away with the sombreros here in your
shop see
yes i'm telling you it's offensive
offensive yes particularly to uh
mexicans no i blameless
join us next week for more in cultural
preparation
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s crowder where i'm tweeting
all day long i'm ticking off the social
justice warriors you should see the
amount of hate i get on there far far
far worse than any fat sports
illustrated model or black lives matter
charlatan so listen it's free you get to
be entertained and you can chime in also
if you're following me on twitter you
can send me your tweets and maybe you'll
be lucky enough and i mean lucky enough
because i have a lot of followers okay
that they call me the follower machine
to have your tweet to me or not gay
jared included in a rockinest tweet of
the week so follow me on twitter at s
crowder if not i don't want to say i
have sights on your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
to you
glad to be back and uh the only thing i
will say to
naked jared right now your punishment
must be masturbating lots of tech
problems here
but we are going to be fixing them
i i you know sometimes let's just blame
the jews
i wouldn't when the church doesn't work
the job the church
the check the check the check check the
check
i don't know
i don't know the exact case so we talked
about a few things earlier we had a
video that went up this morning and i
wanted to talk about it because when we
did this video it was like 30 minutes
right not gay jared before we cut it
down yeah it was yeah
and it's this idea some for some reason
people have bought into the idea of
democratic socialism everything old is
new again you see the you see the girls
now walking around with the high-waisted
pants they look like ferris bueller's
sister it's true it's true it's not
entirely awful but it's it's pretty bad
yeah it's pretty bad i don't think it's
bad i don't mind the look you don't like
the high-waisted pants i go back and
forth on it i don't know
guys or girls no girls i don't think
guys are doing it are guys doing the
full shwayzey roadhouse tweet me at s
crowder is that a trend now
i've been looking the wrong way well
schweizey can pull it off
swayze can do a good job of that there's
there's no one more masculine doing a
pirouette than patrick swayze
the world lost to talent
so
democratic socialism everything old is
new again this is what bernie sanders
puts out there and we felt it necessary
to debunk this a lot of people when
you're you're listening to rest really
say well why aren't you focusing on
hillary
there will be plenty of time to focus on
hillary if she's the nominee
trust us we have plenty in store we need
to pace ourselves here
but right now bernie is the movement
candidate
hillary will win probably because of the
way the system operates and the super
delegates go now keep in mind that i
think at this point in the last election
hillary was a deadlock and the super
delegates a lot of them went the other
way with barack obama
highly unlikely with bernie because he's
been out he he's been more of an outcast
whereas barack obama wasn't unknown
i don't think bernie has that many
friends in the democratic party compared
to barack obama so it's very likely that
it goes to hillary clinton because
democracy it's nothing but super
delegates who pick the nominee
um but the reason we focus on bernie
sanders is because obviously as a
younger american under 30.
he's the guy who people are really
looking to he's more popular than barack
obama in a lot of ways he's the movement
candidate and people really believe that
democratic socialism is somehow
different from socialism socialism we
talked about this we have it up at the
site from the democratic socialists of
america their very own site they they
talk about how they believe that means
of production should be put in the hands
of the workers how basically the
eventual goal is to do away with private
corporations
this is what people believe and
something that's interesting it came out
we talked about this earlier i think
maybe i didn't talk about it earlier i
think i was talking on maybe a glenn
beck's show about it there have been
polls that have come out
something that's very telling cuban
americans ted cruz talked about this you
were either republican or a communist
that's how they saw you but for the
first time in a recent poll younger
cuban americans it's flipped where 57 of
them i don't know the exact numbers in
front of me
have a positive view
of socialism
and
that's a first but what does that tell
you what the poll doesn't tell you is
these are kids who were raised in the
united states
they didn't come from cuba
they didn't come from a socialist
country or it's a lot of that girl that
was at the uh the bernie rally remember
her she talked about her parents had a
unfavorable view of socialized medicine
came from canada right she just couldn't
grasp why they were so turned off by it
and they're like oh you've spent your
entire life in america you don't really
know anything no so and and she doesn't
seem to like america very much i don't i
don't think she's why don't you go back
to your home on [ __ ] island it would be
a it's not an island to be fair but it's
it's more of a peninsula it is yeah it's
more of a peninsula we know people will
fact check us on that
but this is something that's okay kids
have embraced it another another study
that came out another poll that came out
you have kids who see it have a favor
something over 50 percent so numbers
were always between 50 and 60. over 50
percent
of people age 35 and younger had a
favorable view of socialism and said
they would be willing to vote for
someone who was self-defined as a
socialist one asked if they were willing
to pay higher taxes however that number
flipped
something very interesting if they had
been in the workforce for three or more
years that number was cut in almost half
so it is true life turns you into uh
something more conservative right life
turns people conservative at least
libertarian once they start paying taxes
if they start paying taxes they see how
painful it is also we didn't talk about
this bernie sanders there was a plan it
was added up the math we have it at the
website if you are making 50 000 a year
okay under a bernie sanders plan there's
this idea people buy for some reason
with bernie sanders and it's something
if you're listening you need to know
this because people assume well since
the rich will pay their fair share the
rich will pay more people pulling the
lever for bernie or hillary think
naturally the middle class and the poor
will pay less no
you'll pay more
the rich will just pay more more
so to give you an example under bernie's
plan the additional tax burden on
someone or a household making 50 000 a
year 50 000 very very far cry from the
top point one percent or one percent or
ten percent unless you're talking
globally than you are in the top ten
percent
fifty thousand dollars a year you will
be paying over five thousand dollars
more than what you're paying currently
under a bernie sanders plan contrast
that with ted cruz where it would be two
thousand dollars less
and donald trump over i think over three
thousand dollars less hillary clinton
was about the same with sixty five
dollars more
now if you make up to a million you'll
be paying 160 000
more with bernie sanders so people see
that number but they don't understand
yeah if you're making fifty thousand
you'll pay five thousand dollars that's
still ten percent
and what people don't tell you what the
bernie sanders plan this democratic
socialism is the six percent payroll tax
which will be passed on to consumers the
mandatory health care tax
something that's really important we
talk about democratic socialism we have
all the numbers in this video and we
talk about why it doesn't work how it
implodes but there is a very very
important ethical component
here
health care health care in school needs
to be a human right
school people should get free school
okay what if i choose not to go to
school
what if i choose not to go to college
what if i choose instead to take one of
those high-paying skilled trade jobs
like mike rowe talks about and start my
own business and make a good income but
i chose not to go to school as a
business decision
what is moral
about taking my money and forcing me to
pay for someone's eight year gender
studies degree
what is moral what if i want to pay bare
minimum health care insurance high
deductible catastrophic and have an hsa
how is it ethical for you to say
no you made this decision but we're
going to charge you anyway and we're
going to do it at gunpoint that's what
the government does scary men take you
away with guns if you don't pay your
taxes
how is that fair how is that just
yeah the numbers don't add up it's also
morally reprehensible to remove
the autonomy of a human being to make
their own choices
and nobody talks about that because oh
the feels and the hugs
speaking of which we're going to get
nice and fuzzy with courtney kirchov
after this stay
only tuned some time
this is breaking news on louder wolf
crawler i'm perry matheson when i'll
take you live to donald trump's campaign
stop in new york
at this week's little league game
all right i love baseball it's the
american past time i played so you know
i could have gone pro if not for the
bose spurs i could have gone pro at ball
a lot of people they said yeah i was so
good at baseball the best okay mr trump
you ready yeah okay frankly throw me
everything you got jimmy hey come on
listen you're throwing here you're
trying to hit me here what's going on i
can't help it you're crowding the plate
i'm not crowded the plate don't get cute
okay all right okay
let's go
hey come on what the hell are you doing
here okay you're trying to hit me i
can't help it i'm only six i'm not that
accurate okay okay all right frankly
i'll show you accurate okay come here
come here come here jimmy come here what
are you doing come on get your trump oh
my god donald trump knocked jimmy
unconscious
okay truthfully
he started it
we will keep you abreast for london with
crowder i'm paris
all right sorry for all the tech issues
that have been going on of course if
you're listening to rest really you
don't face any of these
because you're only listening through
your radio isn't that nice on with us oh
gosh i guess i need to get her theme
song ready this is a nightmare tonight
jared
people are calling for your firing all
over right now do you realize this
yeah and you didn't have your microphone
on it's pretty much normal day
okay when you hear the sound you know
who it is
you can follow her at courtney scoffs
because she scoffs at you
courtney kirchhoff is with us courtney
can you can you hear me
there you go look at you all blonde your
tan is slowly fading though
well it shouldn't be because i'm working
on it it's been sunny all week here well
maybe it's just glorious
i have no idea but with those high-tech
headphones she looks like the blonde guy
in the burger king kids club remember
the one with the gadgets
yeah do you remember the burger king
kids club courtney no it wasn't the
crowns were the best part it was the
crown but there was a break it was like
the perfectly politically correct club
there was the black kid with the high
and tight hair there was a redhead there
was the girl who was in the wheelchair
there was the tomboy and there was the
tech nerd so everyone was included
the burger king kids club it's cool to
be a kid i can't believe you don't
remember and eat me and no i can't
remember that
yeah whenever you see the care bears
though remember the care bears the care
bears
well zuckerberg believes that that is a
fulcrum for foreign policy so i think
it's been more influential than people
realize i mean now wait a second have we
tried it yet have we tried have we tried
when isis is going after us just saying
hey you guys let's just hug it out
to be fair we can't 100 say no
right so um
one time and he you know whoever
attempted it just got blown to bits
that's true i don't i don't know because
generally speaking the people who've
tried it probably never lived to tell
the tale speaking of which you got a lot
of flack you were exposed to the
underbelly of of the internet when you
wrote about how real men can't vote for
bernie sanders you've written a couple
of columns this week we've written some
together some you've written by yourself
which one has has garnered the biggest
reaction for you and and
what are the colorful names people are
using
well after the bernie sanders you're not
a real man i still stand by that by the
way even if you're a socialist and
you're working and you're providing for
yourself if you still believe that other
men or other people should pay for other
people even if you're working you're
you're still not a man
that's fair so the column the column
that i wrote tonight was um millennials
they're this love with socialism this
infatuation they have with socialism is
going to unwind america
um the reason that is
american exceptionalism the reason we're
exceptional it's not because we think
americans are better than everyone else
though i do think
parentheses i was inside parentheses we
we we are
um but it's it's because our country was
founded on the notion that man is free
that people are free to make their own
choices they're free to leave their own
lives socialism comes in and says no
you're you're really not um we're the
government we've been elected we read
off teleprompters we're going to tell
you how to how to best lead your life
and we're going to make everything fair
and equal
and those who are successful and get all
of their their finances removed from
them simply have to bend thank you sir i
have another one and take it and take it
yes
yeah and that's just wholly un-american
and unfortunately a lot of millennials
it just sounds so nice and fuzzy
socialism equality it's fairness
you know privilege is wiped out nobody
has advantages anymore well
that that means that nobody can be great
right it's a good point and i think you
touched on something that a lot of
people don't realize you know we talk
about cult cultural appropriation people
talk about culture
um a lot of time you know a lot of the
time people say well america is the only
country that does this
that's kind of the point that is
american culture i mean if we have to
turn a blind eye to islamic culture or
what is a horrible culture mexican
culture you look at what they have they
have a very defined culture
american culture is a set of ideals and
those ideals included the rejection of a
big centralized government whether it be
through a monarchy which paved the way
of course for basically european
socialism i don't understand why people
can't
accept that america is the only country
that does this well you don't have a
problem when mexico is the only country
that does this you don't have a problem
when sweden's the only country that does
this you have a problem when nicaragua
is the only country why is it a problem
when the united states is the only one
to do it
is it just because we kick ass and take
names
i think so we're the only one who's
landed on the moon
we're the only country who's probably
going to cure cancer we're the only
country
who's done a lot of things and maybe
it's because we don't have these stupid
socialist programs for ninis who can't
take care of themselves
i think what we have now people who
don't know how to take care of
themselves and as soon as they learn as
soon as they start paying for themselves
they don't want to pay for everyone else
who decides you know
i just don't feel like working it's too
hard it's not fair that's inevitable
if there's yeah and there's a huge
switch as soon as people start working
for themselves
and you ask me you just talked about it
as soon as you ask them okay well we'll
we'll do all these social programs the
problem is you're going to have to fit
the bill all of a sudden it's oh no no
no no i i didn't mean that i don't i
mean i'm just i'm just kidding right i
don't actually want socialism yeah
you're no longer on your parents plan
so here buy your health no no no no well
you have to face you have to pay the
penalty i'll go back to my parents plan
no you can't do that damn it
and it's called the shared
responsibility
right
share responsibility i i don't even know
how that works um do you think it'll fix
itself though i mean listen you look at
the baby boomers and that was a switch
you had the pot smoke and hippies who
then became one of the most conservative
generations ever which of course is
bemoaned by the writers the staff
writers at huffpo
um
it seems like now these bernie sanders
kids are just the san francisco retreads
do you think as they get skinned in the
game they'll just become more
conservative
i sure hope so
every generation before always talks
about how the next generation is just a
bunch of whiny babies that's true so um
so there's hope i also saw a poll just a
little while ago that said millennials
favor ted cruz way over donald trump and
hillary clinton
i don't
remember exactly why they did
i am skeptical of that we've also never
seen a real conservative
leader we've never seen it we've had we
were too young for reagan
um you know we were too young i was just
starting to remember i still i can only
remember bill clinton barely i just
remember my parents and going oh my gosh
i can't believe we have this but we were
too young we've not seen actual
conservatives bill clinton forced the
birds and the bees talk to be thrust
upon an entire generation a little
earlier than mom and pop
wanted it to be so true i didn't know
what they knew
what your definition of is is i don't
know what the word neuter meant until
the the remember the phrase neuter bill
that was a big thing that came out yeah
that was i didn't know i i learned i
learned yeah i remember my dad did that
whole is is i was like what does he mean
he goes well what he means is he has had
sex with women who weren't his wife but
he's not he goes but
he goes and you know what sex is you
know what sex i taught you about that
how babies are made penis and vagina
that that's you you know sex he goes i
was like no i don't need to explain it
because what he is trying to say is i
have had sex with women who are not my
wife but i am not currently under this
table while he was in the stand i go dad
that's are you are you pulling one on me
because no no that's what he was trying
to do and that was the day i decided i
was a republican
also little known fact
talk about being young my wife
checked her closet for o.j simpson
wow yeah i remember that too fifth grade
i was in fifth grade when i was going on
so all she saw was the tabloids
murderer's wife o.j simpson so she just
saw the headlines and she thought he was
a monster she was terrified of o.j
simpson
and yet the jury acquitted him
so racist she's just a racist yeah
your wife's a racist she is a racist uh
and then uh and then it was uh now
there's the the og i haven't watched the
oj show i hear john travolta is really
gay unnecessarily yeah he's kind of
creepy in it but that said i i actually
kind of enjoy the show and i maybe i'm
just it's really stupid but
this one doesn't seem to have a really
particular
black lives matter bent that it could
have it talks a lot about it but it
pains them more and favorably than the
prosecution no no no o.j is a black eye
on the black lives matter people they
all know he did it well they well sure
but they they could have gone that way
with this series and they haven't which
is funny because the next one they're
supposed to talk about the next season
supposed to be on katrina and it's
called american crime series so you know
what angle they're taking with that one
you know who is the villain why don't we
have questions if you're just gonna talk
shut up these are good questions with my
my blonde hair
yeah cause he's not getting these are
good questions
it's it's it's a problem okay
stop it jared this is a nice lady
um okay so you wrote this column on the
millennials what what's the reaction
coming i know a lot of i don't like to
just crap on millennials because they
can be very innovative they can be very
productive so yeah i mean the three of
us are millennials right you don't suck
i don't think i mean there are we're
gonna get tweets that say okay actually
i've got news for you damn it president
you guessed it
it's true i'm not i wouldn't put my i
wouldn't put it past me but um
that's one thing a lot of republicans
just lose them and i think if people
listen you wrote you write a headline
and it's
eye-catching but if people read it it's
informative
and it just seems like
it should be a flip it's uplifting see i
think
i really think a big problem here is
it's a cultural one
a lot of people of our generation were
raised in a single parent household or
to divorced parents
my mother told me from a young age you
can do anything you put your mind to she
told it to me multiple times it's stuck
i think a lot of
people didn't have that they didn't have
a support system so they're looking to
daddy government to support them now
i i wish
it's hard to work for yourself it's hard
to be independent it's hard to be free
but it's way better
than being a succubus on the government
teat no it is for you it is for you it
is for me respectfully a lot of people
it's why there are fewer business owners
than there are people who want to look
for jobs i'm taking it that's a less
extreme version but a lot of people
don't feel bad about themselves being
being on welfare with a smartphone and
hate tweeting you
that's that may be true and that's scary
um but if they think if they think
that's the norm if they don't know
there's something better out there
um
you know
i don't know what to tell them it's true
yeah i i think there are a lot of people
on welfare who don't believe in
themselves it's
you know if you go to a state park they
tell you not to feed the animals why
because they're going to get dependent
so we're doing that to people though
we're feeding the people and we're not
letting them fend for themselves and
pretty
pretty
pretty good i like that analogy yeah
i do and it's the same people right that
are saying don't feed the deer the deer
need to forage well no bears
in yellowstone that's a big problem and
then people see the park rangers you
know taking out a bear and they've done
everything they can you know they'll
they'll scare them away from people they
want them to be scared from people
because that's the only way they're
independent and then people think it's
mean and they're going no we're not
we're actually not being mean we're the
people who are we've studied bears our
whole lives if they keep coming in it's
going to be dangerous they can kill we
have to get them back out of here you
give them a few picnic baskets and send
them on their way and all of a sudden
they're labeled they're labeled as um as
hate mongers against bears that is a
good analogy don't feed the animals my
uh my grandparents live on the water in
florida with uh with gators literally in
their backyard and they've had neighbors
eating because they got too friendly and
and fed the gators over and over and
over again want to hear a table turkey
oh nice does it taste like chicken it
actually it does it tastes kind of like
a middle ground between chicken and
calamari sorry i interrupted you good
courtney continue
no i was going to make a joke about
don't feed the bernie sanders people or
they're going to eat you like an
alligator
not your best work no
no so maybe it was good that i was
interrupted
i am dead inside i wouldn't you need to
write better
i just i don't know i have come to
expect so much of her and then every now
and then she just disappeared yeah i am
funny in writing not as funny in person
no but i think it's a good point i hope
people do read it it is a column that i
think a lot of people need to read and
there's a lot of information in there in
like we've talked about this is kind of
a movement among millennials right now
that i think a lot of older people
aren't aware just how comfortable they
are with full-fledged socialism
yeah and we also you know what we also
are a generation we have the mark
zuckerbergs who is uh two weeks younger
than me so hashtag perspective hashtag i
suck
um so we have people who are where i age
who are billionaires and we look at them
and go god that would be nice that's not
fair and we still we start with that
that's not fair this is true but we have
to go
follow her at courtney scoffs and of
course read her writing at lottery with
crowder.com courtney thank you so much
we'll have you back louder with crowder
stay tuned
this week in cultural appropriation
no more
so glad we're out here marching the
chinese have had their culture
appropriated long enough yeah totally
i'm with you does anyone know why chang
didn't show up yeah where is chad hey
there he is chang chang we're doing the
protest for the chinese slippers why
aren't you here with us china is a
sweeper yeah the chinese slippers it's
offensive you should be marching with us
in unity
are too busy taking your job what
yes i just buy a shop across the street
you mean the one where i work used to
work
enjoy your match
join us next week for more in cultural
appropriation
all right glad to be back last hour
last segment last segment last hour last
segment of the show i'd like to say this
show went by quickly but good lord
um
always grateful to be to be here to be
with you to be picked up by more
stations and and growing online
uh by the next time i speak with you the
election the primary will have shaken up
possibly quite differently from today
with wisconsin
and uh i guess it's it's it's a big
battleground state right now and um it
seems like things are changing also i'll
probably
have deployed elsewhere
not gay jared we definitely need to seek
employment elsewhere
if anyone out there is looking
for
a
right in the middle of the pack
depending on his mood
producer
editor
he might be your man
and that's actually what i've written on
his letter of recommendation i just have
stacks of them at the ready
but no one takes them
well you got you you gotta no you have
the jacks of all trades then you got
like the eights
and the those have to exist too i'm i'm
kind of like the four of all trades do
you know that for you to the jacks and
the aces you know that expression a jack
of all trades master of
i'm going to let uh back to you stephen
jack of all trades master of none not
none yeah you've heard that yeah yeah
that's not the actual phrase really
the actual phrase i i have hope morgan i
think
told me about this it may have been on
the show about a year ago and i don't
know if it was madison
uh washington it was one of the the
founding fathers
somewhere back there i so please don't
misquote me here someone can find it my
internet's not working
it was jack of all trades master of one
and it was basically and it was really
in the context of for a man clearly
there was an asian there somewhere
translating this phrase over the decades
no then it was used to mock the phrase
and the mocking phrase became more
popular than the original phrase the
mocking phrase became the colloquial
colloquialism
no i didn't have a stroke i just
mispronounced a word
you could forgive donald trump why not
me i'm going to use the best words so
master of a jack of all trades master of
one was the term and that was actually
it was spoken in reference if you look
at its context i remember reading about
this gosh i wish i had it in front of me
of what is required for a man to succeed
particularly excellence
teddy roosevelt wrote a lot about this i
know he was he sort of expanded
government to a level with which i
wasn't comfortable but personally a
fascinating
fascinating
character in history
the idea that a man needs to be equipped
needs to be capable needs to be adept in
all areas
but um but absolutely fantastic in one
is how you succeed is what is necessary
to be a completed man
so it's one thing if you're an
intellectual yeah you still need to be
able to do some push-ups you still need
to be able to uh
to clean up around the house you still
need to be able to survive right if
you're a great soldier you still need to
be able to read books you still need to
be able to process information you still
need to be able to communicate
effectively but
everyone has an area where they are are
specialized and that's one thing i think
people have done a disservice courtney
just said it but i know what she meant
the idea that you can put your you can
do anything you put your mind to that's
true
to a degree
obviously not like flight or
invisibility
maybe one day
i don't think so yet
i haven't been to area 51 i've heard
good things the point is
what we don't tell kids is listen find
your purpose live in your purpose and
you certainly won't hear that from the
left
the idea that anyone has a divine
purpose or that people were put on this
earth or designed
for one specific thing
it runs entirely counter to the idea of
socialism in the collective ironically
it comes back around with extreme
communism right if you're born in china
and you have the right you have the
right body dimensions
you're going to be on the olympic
gymnastics team don't expect a monthly
cycle until you're 14 because they're
going to keep your weight down and tie
up your toes this is true they put
an axe in your hand you're going to be
manual labor you're going to be a
scientist that's how they decide what
you get to do so that flies in the face
of course the government decides now
government is god but the idea of
socialism but everyone takes part that
people should be equal same thing i was
just speaking at american university
they weren't allowed to play touch
football that was an event for the club
and they said it was too competitive
that is
anti-not only anti-american
exceptionalism that is anti i guess
deism for anyone who believes that you
have some kind of a purpose so you can
do anything you put your mind to but
here's what's important and this is
what's lost in the self-esteem
generation
take take michael phelps for example
greatest swimmer ever
people look at him and go well he smokes
weed and eats mcdonald's so i can too no
listen he is a freak
he was designed in a way that is perfect
with hands the size of meat hooks
and size 18 feet and long he was
designed in a way where he would be the
best regardless he he's fantastic in
spite of mcdonald's and smoking weed of
course he trained unbelievably hard so
people just see the one thing the
mcdonald's and he said well if it's good
enough for phelps look look they're
sipping their dr pepper that's not how
it works
some of these athletes are fantastic in
spite of their training and sometimes
you get that magic where someone is
living in their purpose they're in
exactly what they were designed to do
where they are brilliant where they are
good
and they work really hard you see that
when you see that it is a sight to
behold have you ever just seen someone
and this is what's so important this is
why men and women you need to challenge
yourselves every day i will tell you
this having having done submission
wrestling it's a very physical endeavor
i have rolled with people who are world
champions and i'm decent
and i've just had to accept listen no
matter what i do
this person was was created to do this
i'm not going to be as good at them even
if i work as hard as i can because i
know this person is also working at this
like a full-time job and that's okay
because i can find
my purpose
and so i think that's what's really
removed we've talked about socialism and
and not only the moral and ethical
aspect but it strips
humans of it strips you of the human
essence
uh humans have have this innate desire
to belong
to be productive to be useful and to
find the way in which they can do that
most effectively socialism says there is
no way there is no purpose the purpose
is all of us you're an amoeba you're not
an individual and i think that's a big
reason why it collapses you can't
quantify it at something intangible that
can't be put on paper but if you tell an
entire nation of people you were all the
same and none of you were created none
of you were fearfully and wonderfully
created different from one another
so we're going to treat you the same and
make everything equal you strip them of
the human spirit don't let that happen
see you next week
you